Ich bin schon wieder da.
So, hörst du mich?
Ich hör was, ich glaub, es hat angefangen.
Computerfree, Computerfree, lebst in deiner Welt. Hacks mit dicken Fingern in die Tastatur. Computerfree, Computerfree, abgeschottet, ausgeschwert, suchst im Chat Erlösung und findest nur dich selbst. Wirklichkeit und Fantasie verschmelzen zu ein Klumpen. Aus virtueller Masse und binären Codes. Fast klar vom Arbeitsspeicher, hockst du in deiner Butze. Essen tust du nur noch, um zu überleben. Computerfree, Computerfree, ungeraschen klebrig. Emotions, Schock, gefrostet, verheddert in der Maus. Computerfree, Computerfree, von Megaherz zu Megaschmerz. Ist das nun das Leben, was du wirklich willst? Abhängig von Updates, Augen gerendert, ungelenkt dein Körper, Sklave deiner Zeit. Festplatte raucht ab, Backup geht verloren, Angst vom nächsten Absturz, wer beherrscht hier wen? Computerfree, Computerfree, Klicks depressiv im Off. Arbeitsspeicher chronisch knapp, Taktung ist beschissen. Computerfree, Computerfree, beidseitig formatierbar. Gefangener von Bites, Joystick der Gefühle. Das Hirn verklumpt mit Datenbrei, Controlling ausgeschlossen. Ist das die schöne Neue Welt oder Horror-Trip? Verdammter Einmannstraße aus Elektrosmog. Dazwischen niemals Land auf Omas und Beamten. Computerfree, Computerfree, digitales Koma. Analoges Zucken in virtueller Qual. Computerfree, Computerfree, Gefangener des Laufwerks. Der Diener wird zum Herrscher, der Sklave wird zum Gott. Computerfree, Computerfree, Armee der Laptop-Zombies. Schlecht getaktet, falsch gepolt, auf DVD versklavt. Computerfree, Computerfree, jung und krank im Ofgedunsen. Icklig fatter Fleischklop, festgebabbt am Schirm.
So ein Geburtsverständchen war das.
Oh, das war ja schön.
Von Heinz Strunk. Heinz, Heinz, Fleisch ist mein Gemüse Strunk, ist das.
Hat der nicht mal das mit diesem Wembel?
Nee, das war Heinz Schenk.
Ach so.
20 Jahre kommt das lustige Glückshälschen von links. Ich kann so nett arbeiten. Und der zweite schöne Satz aus diesem Film war, du warst super Heinz, nur das Orchester war einen Tag zu früh.
Was hab ich da jetzt wieder losgetreten?
Nichts, nichts, nichts. Erzähl doch mal, was hier los ist. Ich versuch mal derweil hier Musik in den Dings zu...
Ja, hallo, willkommen beim Chaosradio, Ausgabe Nummer 108, was nicht so spektakulär klingt. Deswegen haben wir mal in den Kalender geguckt und festgestellt, ach Hottchen, 10 Jahre Chaosradio sind jetzt komplett. November 1995 haben wir angefangen mit einer Sendung, von der es leider keine Aufzeichnung gibt, wie auch von den zehn darauffolgenden Sendungen, warum wir das nicht hingekriegt haben, weiß ich bis heute noch nicht. Ich lasse, also ich glaube daran, aber ich kann hier ja mal mein modernes, mobiles Abspielgerät zum Start bringen.
Also es hat auf jeden Fall im Radio bei den Hörern da draußen, als du den Stecker rausgezogen hast. Es lag am Endgerät, es lag am Endgerät.
Es lag am Endgerät, warte mal, jetzt muss ich aber hier erstmal ein bisschen... Macintosh. Ganz schön zerkratzt dein iPod.
Mac, was ist denn jetzt los?
So, jetzt spule ich hier mal verkrampft zurück.
Das hat doch was, das hat doch schon was.
Das hat doch was, das geht rein, das ist digital. Ich sag's dir.
So, worum geht's?
Okay, 10 Jahre Chaosradio, hat er dir gerade erzählt.
10 Jahre Chaosradio, aber nicht nur 10 Jahre Chaosradio, sondern auch 10 Jahre alles. Alles, genau. Das hast du schön gesagt, Jens. Und 10 Jahre alles heißt, wir wollen ein bisschen parallel blicken auf Chaosradio, auch auf die Zeit, weil in den letzten 10 Jahren sich einfach mal massiv was geändert hat in unserer Umgebung, zumindest aus unserer Perspektive. Und das wollen wir auch gerne mit euch diskutieren. Und natürlich hat es auch Einflüsse auf den CCC gehabt, sogar nicht ganz unerhebliche, wie man sagen kann, im Rückblick. Ich weiß noch, wir hatten das Thema der ersten Sendung war eigentlich gar kein Thema, sondern das Thema der ersten Sendung war so der Chaos Computer Club. Leider gibt es davon, wie gesagt, keine Aufzeichnung mehr. Ich habe da noch irgendwelche Echoes irgendwo im Kopf, aber ein zuverlässiger Datenspeicher ist das ja nicht.
Das sind keine Echoes, du hörst Stimmen, nur reden die in einer Sprache, die du nicht beherrschst.
Das ist angenehm, das ist besser, als wenn sie einem sagen, töte ihn, töte ihn, töte ihn.
Ja, und deswegen haben wir uns hier zusammengefunden, um das Ganze auch mit euch mal ein bisschen zu diskutieren, wie eure Erlebnisse in den letzten zehn Jahren gewesen sind, wie euch Technik beeinflusst hat, was ihr anders macht heute, als ihr es vor zehn Jahren gemacht habt, oder was ihr vielleicht glaubt, wie ihr es vor zehn Jahren gemacht habt, weil ihr mangels ausreichenden Altersdaten nicht so den Vergleich habt.
Das kann ja auch sein.
Und dafür haben wir auch eine tolle Telefonnummer freigeschaltet, die Holger immer so super auswendig kann.
033 177 97 110.
Du bist ein Zahlenkönig. Nicht mal überlegt, mal dieses Nummernstück von Kraftwerk nachzusingen. Dann hätten wir das mal auch mal so lizenzfrei.
Kraftzahl 0331.
Kannst du den Vorhang, den Ohrhang wieder zumachen?
Der Geruch kommt von meinen Schuhen. Ich bin da in was getreten.
Ja, 10 Jahre Chaosradio. Ein paar Sachen war ja früher anders. Manche Sachen sind immer noch gleich. Wir sind immer noch nicht vorbereitet. Wir bringen immer noch unsere Club-Mate mit.
Habt ihr mir eine Mate mitgebracht?
Ja, natürlich haben wir eine Mate mitgebracht. Hier müsste irgendwo eine Mate. Eine Geburtstagmate. Geburtstagmate. Es wird ja überhaupt, im Club wollten sie uns ja fast keine mitgeben. Ja, es sei das Mate-Notstand. Mate-Knappheit. Also es sei nur noch, es wurde irgendeine große Zahl genannt und alle Shorten besorgt.
Und dann werd ich nach der Sendung mal vorbeikommen.
Ja, Mate.
Und dann klären wir das mal.
Ich kümmere mich mal kurz in die Mate.
Warte, warte, der Tim der rund die Mate.
Aber ein paar Sachen sind ja auch anders. Also zum Beispiel dieses Studio, in dem wir hier sitzen, ist ja toll, neu, modern, irgendwie mit Windows 98 Computer. Nein, NT.
Sie nennen den nix NT.
Das ist XP mittlerweile. Oder?
Geupgraded, natürlich. Oder ist das ein Skin?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich meine, es wäre XP. Also wir haben neuerdings USB. Das heißt, es kann kein NT sein.
Ich find das ja schon komisch, dass das hier überhaupt eingeloggt ist. Können wir das mal auslösen?
Aber das war ja früher alles noch anders. Da gab es irgendwie dieses Haus und irgendwie es gab diese Baustelle, diese sehr bemerkenswerte Baustelle, die sich über mehrere Jahre um das Studio herum erstreckte. Und jeden Monat mussten wir woanders lang fahren. Und ein kleines, doch eher benutztes Studio, wo wir uns dann auch mal die Freiheit genommen haben, eine oder andere Tüte zu rauchen, was hier in diesem Studio jetzt natürlich nicht mehr geht, weil da viel teure PCs drinne stehen und nicht mehr bloß ein paar alte Schiebelriegler.
Das ist gar nicht so das Problem. Das Hauptproblem ist, dass die Feuermelder mittlerweile direkt bei der Feuerwehr auflaufen und früher erstmals beim Fördner geklingelt hat, der dann gekommen ist und geguckt hat, was dampft.
Oh ja, und die Kondensatormikrofone, die Kondensatormikrofone.
Aber es ging auch. Es war immerhin schon deutlich professioneller als viele Podcasts heutzutage, die an dem Bild in Mikrofonen des Laptops auf den Leuten beim Küchengisch entstehen. War schon richtig Radio. Der CCC ist ja sowieso offensichtlich den klassischen Medien doch noch sehr verhaftet. Wir geben unsere Vereinsmitteilung noch auf Papier heraus. Wir machen noch Sendung im Radio und nicht im Internet.
Auf analogen Funkfrequenzen, wolltest du sagen?
Ja, auf analogen Funkfrequenzen. So wie früher kann man mit 80 Jahre alten Empfängern empfangen.
Trotzdem war Chaosradio aber auch eins der ersten im Internet als digitale Aufzeichnung verfügbaren Radiosendungen.
Auch das. Das Bemerkenswerte an Chaosradio ist, denke ich, dass wir diese Phase mitgemacht haben in der Zeit, wo wir waren alleine im Internet, zu jetzt sind alle anderen auch im Internet mitgemacht haben. Quasi die digitale Revolution mit unserer Sendung so ein bisschen begleitet haben auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Die digitale Revolution, ja. Home Alone. Ja, ihr hört schon, wir haben hier eine ganze Menge Zettel mitgebracht. Und eine ganze Menge Leute. Vielleicht sollten wir mal sagen, wer überhaupt da ist. Genau. Dann fangen wir doch mal mit dir an, Jens. Ich bin der Jens.
Das andere ist der Tim. Und dann sitzt da der Andreas.
Und der Holger.
Und wir sind alle vier.
Wir sind so vier. Jetzt steigt der Humorlevel.
Okay, Chaosradio.
Chaosradio musste unbedingt Chaosradio heißen. Weil wir ja der Chaos Computer Club sind. Und das war eigentlich eine relativ schnelle Entscheidung am Anfang. Ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern, ich war im Urlaub irgendwo in Afrika, ganz weit weg kam wieder und Frank erzählte mir von, ich würde jetzt Radio machen, was mir total neu war. Und dann hatten wir halt sozusagen in meiner Abwesenheit diese Idee ausgeknobelt, damals noch mit Johnny. Grüße an Johnny, der ja bei der letzten Sendung dabei war. Und ach, das war schön. Dann saßt man irgendwie schön zusammen und hat ein Vorbereitungstreffen gemacht. Das ist immer ganz toll, richtig schön CCC-mäßig. Zwei Stunden lang hat man sich alle möglichen Ideen herangezogen, die einem nur so kommen können als Nerd, was man nicht alles macht, Interviews, Einspielungen, Schnick Schnack, Trailer, Jingles. Das war dann schon so der Plan für die nächsten zehn Jahre.
Wir haben, glaube ich, noch nicht alles realisiert.
Letzten Endes war es halt einfach eine entspannte Geschichte. So kann ich mich da auch noch erinnern, wie wir sozusagen so an das Format gefunden haben, indem wir halt einfach losgeschwatzt haben über was auch immer uns gerade in den Sinn kam.
Chaosradio 108. Ich lasse die Ordnungszahl mal weg. 10 Jahre Chaosradio heute auf Fritz.
Genau, die Digitale Dekade.
Genau, wollen wir mal Journalismus machen oder sowas in der Art?
Oh ja, mach mal, mach mal.
Wer hatte eigentlich die Idee damals? 1995 zum Chaosradio. Irgendjemand muss doch mal die Idee gehabt haben.
Ja, es gab dann halt so Kontakte zwischen so und dann grüßt man eine Gruppe von den Leuten, die so damals den CCCB gestartet haben und Johnny. Und in dem Kontext ist halt einfach, keine Ahnung, einfach die Idee aufgekommen, man könnte ja mal. Und dann wurde das irgendwie angesprochen und offensichtlich bei Fritz dann doch sehr wohlwollend aufgenommen. Und so kam das halt. Also es gibt eigentlich keine große, furiose Geschichte. Also zumindest nicht so, weißt du da was drüber?
Na, es gab doch da diese Kooperation zwischen Firmen und dem Sender hier mit EU-Mitteln, die unbedingt ausgegeben werden mussten. Und so lande man sich glaube ich kennen.
Damals, nee, Firmen mit EU-Mitteln, die aus, kannst du mal konkret werden? Also die Wahrheit ist immer konkret, Andrea.
Die Wahrheit ist konkret.
Es gab Leute, die in Firmen arbeiten, die an Projekten arbeiten, die auch was mit dem ORB zu tun hatten. Aber das spielt ja nicht so die große Rolle. Wichtig ist, dass Johnny da einen Kontakt gehabt hat zu Leuten von uns. Und dann war die Idee da und dann ging das auch alles relativ fix. Also das war eine Entscheidung, die ist innerhalb von ein paar Wochen geboren und zufeld worden.
Wie war die Reaktion so, hey, endlich ein Hacker-Hobby, wir machen Radio? Oder habt ihr euch vorgenommen damals? Also gesagt, jetzt sagen wir der Welt, wie es immer schon mal war.
Es gab ja auch so die Außenperspektive. Also das war eine relativ Berliner Geschichte. Ist ja heute auch immer noch so.
Du kommst jetzt zum Beispiel gerade aus Bonn.
Ich komme aus Bonn und bin im CCC Köln aktiv. Genau und das war auch für den Chaos Computer Club ganz interessant in der Zeit, weil dann die Berliner hieß es dann ja immer für uns. Die Berliner, die waren dann plötzlich auch hörbar und so. Vorher so Ende der 80er, Mitte der 80er war das eigentlich eine relativ Hamburger Geschichte der Chaos Computer Club. Man ist dann zwar immer einmal im Jahr aus der ganzen Republik zusammengekommen und hat in Hamburg da das Familientreffen gefeiert. Aber dann fing es plötzlich auch an, dass man gemerkt hat, an anderen Ecken der Republik regt sich was. Und da war das Chaos Radio auf jeden Fall ganz, ganz wichtig. Mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass es in ganz vielen Regionen von Deutschland Versuche gibt, so was Ähnliches wie Chaos Radio dann auch zu machen. Also Leute in Ulm sind da relativ gut dabei in ziemlich vielen Ecken. Diese Idee Chaos Radio wird dann halt auch mit anderen Schwerpunkten umgesetzt.
Sonst noch irgendwo einen UKW-Sender gibt es nicht, oder?
Doch, doch. Also es gibt verschiedene regionale Gruppen, also vom CCC, die regelmäßige Sendungen machen. Und das eben nicht nur im Internet, sondern in der Regel in freien Radios. Also da muss man sicherlich C-Radar nennen aus Darmstadt.
Genau. Das ist aber auch auf Darmstadt beschränkt oder besenden die ganz Hessen damit? Nein, das ist eine lokale Sache.
Ich glaube, das geht über so ein Studenten, Uni, sonst was Radio. Also so richtig fett mit öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk, der so über ein ganzes Bundesland powert, läuft das nur hier. Aber es gibt auch andere Versuche. Ja, zumal es halt auch, ja, ich meine, jetzt gibt es halt auch Internet, also alle streamen und auch bei Chaosradio ist das ja schon eine ganze Weile so, dass wir eigentlich unsere Kerngruppe nicht ausschließlich über UKW erfassen.
Naja, die können ja auch da, wo sie wohnen, zum Teil gar nicht.
Wir hatten das ja häufig, dass Leute angerufen haben aus, was weiß ich, aus Stuttgart, aus allen Teilen Deutschlands.
Also, wo einfach deutsch gesprochen wird.
Ja, genau, ja, aber auch teilweise aus dem Ausland. Ich hatte glaube ich einmal sogar jemand aus den USA dabei, den wir zwar kannten, aber der halt auch in der Lage war, einfach der Sendung live zu folgen und das eben schon vor vielen Jahren. Das ist natürlich heutzutage, ich weiß dann das keinem mehr vom Sofa, aber damals war das eben irgendwie ganz toll. Aber vielleicht sollte man mal kurz diese anderen Radios auch erwähnen, weil die sind auch recht fleißig dabei. Also schon erwähnt haben wir C-Radar, Darmstadt, c- Radar.cdcde, dann gibt es das Dev Radio aus vom R-V-Kreis Ulm. Aus dem R-V-Kreis ist das, das können wir auch gleich nochmal erklären.
Klingt ein bisschen esoterisch.
Ja, ist es auch. Findet ihr auf Ulm und TTCDN?
Es steht auf dem festen Boden des deutschen Vereinsrechts. Ja bitte nicht lustig machen drüber, es sind irgendwie Kulturgeschichte.
Ja, dann gibt es gleich mehrere Radioprojekte aus Karlsruhe. Von den ganz umtriebigen Leuten von Entropia e.V. also Chaos Computer Club Karlsruhe, aber die wollten dann auch einen anderen Namen, haben sich dann Entropia e.V. genannt. Radio Chaotica auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite gibt es noch ein anderes Projekt, was auch da lose verwandelt ist, das nennt sich Radio Saugnapf. Da wird Musik gespielt, die aus dem Internet gesaugt werden kann, wurde, wurde.
Genau.
Das läuft dann aber auf, also auch wieder auf dem freien Radio. In dem Fall ist das der Querfunk. Dann gibt es in Wien noch Nerds on Air. Das läuft auf Radio Orange.
Leibernd.
Genau, das war total leibernd.
Aber da können wir jetzt nicht wirklich mithalten. Haben wir noch einen vergessen? Nö, ich glaube, das war es so im Kern und mal schauen mit den Podcasting Phänomenen sehe ich da noch so sehr viel mehr kommen. Und alles das halt, weil irgendwann mal Leute auf die Idee gekommen sind, bei Fritz eine Radiosendung zu machen. Also das war schon nicht eine Zahlendung. Wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, gründet man einen R-Verkreis.
Hast du einen Opa, schick ihn nach Europa.
Weißt du, was ein R-Verkreis ist?
Ist das ein Erfahrungsaustauschskreis?
Das hast du aber schön gemerkt.
Inwiefern steht denn das eigentlich auf den Statuten?
Was hast du gerade gesagt?
Fest auf dem Boden des deutschen Vereinsrechts.
Kannst du das mal erläutern?
Na ja, es handelt sich um eine regionale Untergliederung eines Zentralverbandes. Das haben wir irgendwann zufällig mal entdeckt. Also der Begriff selber kommt aus dem Vereinsrecht? Ja, der Erfahrungsausflusskreis nicht. Das heißt überall anders. Also beim ADAC heißt es Gauer. Die sind noch nicht ganz in diesem Jahrtausend angekommen.
Das ist der einzige Verein, der die Republik noch in Gauer aufteilt, oder?
Aber das ist vereinsrechtlich dasselbe.
Okay, Gauer.
Genau, Verein. Der CCC ist ja ein Verein geworden, um...
Teilweise.
Was heißt teilweise?... der terroristischen Vereinigung zu entgehen.
Naja, es gibt den Chaos Computer Club als Idee und es gibt den CCC e.V. Und man kann in dem einen sein, man kann im anderen sein, idealerweise ist man im beiden.
Also als Tarnungsgründen haben wir, also wir waren glaube ich persönlich alle drei nicht dabei, aber damals Leute, die den CCC gegründet haben, haben beschlossen, es ist besser als würde man so tun, als würde man sich in diese Gesellschaft nahtlos einfügen, wenn man dann eine nicht ganz so große Angriffsfläche bietet, während man versucht die Gesellschaft auseinanderzunehmen.
Wer war da? Und es war......groß.
Und deswegen kommt der nächste Sommer wieder.
Fritz präsentiert Robbie Williams Live. 27. Juli 2006 Leider total ausverkauft. Doch in diesem Zusammenhang bedanken wir uns bei Dr. Ibrahim Zusatz für die Erfindung des Zusatzkonzertes. Fritz präsentiert auch das Zusatzkonzert von Robbie Williams am 28. Juli 2006 im Olympiastadion Berlin. Karten dafür gibt's überall, wo's Karten gibt. Robbie Williams in Berlin und im Radio.
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat in ihrer ersten Regierungserklärung eine Reformpolitik der kleinen Schritte angekündigt. Die Große Koalition werde zeigen, welche Möglichkeiten es in Deutschland gebe. Merkel forderte Mut zu Veränderungen. Nach dem Fleischskandal gehen Bund und Länder jetzt in die Offensive. Verbraucherschutzminister Seehofer hat ein 10-Punkte-Programm präsentiert. Es sieht unter anderem eine EU-weite Meldepflicht für verdorbene Lebensmittel vor. In Ostdeutschland hat die rechte Szene laut einer Studie an Anziehungskraft verloren. Befragt wurden 1000 Schüler im Alter zwischen 14 und 18 Jahren. Die große Mehrheit sagt, dass sie mit Rechten nichts zu tun haben will. Im Fußball-UEFA-Pokal spielt Hertha BSC gerade auswärts gegen Genua. Kurz vor dem Schlusspfiff steht es immer noch 0 zu 0 unentschieden in der Nachspielzeit. Heute Nacht ist es vor allem im Norden noch stark bewölkt und es gibt etwa Schneeregen. Ansonsten klart es langsam auf. Vorsicht, auf den Straßen kann es glatt sein. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus ein und minus vier Grad. Morgens ist es wieder mal heiter. Nee, immer wieder mal heiter, aber nicht andauernd heiter. Es bleibt auch trocken dabei. Die Temperaturen steigen auf ein bis drei Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz mit einer Meldung. Die Strelitzer Straße ist zwischen Bernauer Straße und Rheinsberger Straße bis morgen Abend wegen eines Kraneinsatzes gesperrt. Ansonsten keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Gerald Kötterheinrich. Drei Minuten nach halb elf.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2, dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Chaosradio 118 Jahre Chaosradio. Hier hat Chaosradio unterdacht. Iblumunov Fritz, 10 Jahre Chaosradio feiern wir.
Und 10 Jahre digitale Kulturgeschichte. Die waren ja doch sehr intensiv.
Wahrscheinlich wäre beides ohne einander kaum gegangen, oder?
Du meinst, ohne Chaosradio hätte es die Internetrevolution nie gegeben?
Ja so sieht es doch wohl mal aus.
Das würde mir nicht passieren. 1995, um da mal kurz drauf zu kommen, ist natürlich schon ein sehr interessantes Jahr gewesen. Ich erinnere mal, was da so damals so hip war. Da kam dann Windows 95 heraus.
Ich fand cool, als alle gesagt haben, wer ist der Internet Explorer?
Der Scheißdreck, der kommt doch nie.
Vergiss es, Netscape ist der Browser der ersten Wahl.
Lange Zeit war auch nicht klar, ob man überhaupt Internet will oder nicht lieber Computer. Es war halt auch eine Zeit, wo einfach viele Dinge noch überhaupt nicht entschieden waren, gerade in Bezug auf Internet. Ich meine, 1995, Windows 95 kam raus, Bill Gates hat ein Buch rausgebracht, das hieß The Road Ahead, der Blick nach vorn, keine Ahnung, wie sie das übersetzt haben. Also da hat er Internet noch nicht mal erwähnt, weil er halt auch einfach nicht die passenden Visionen am Start hat. Der hat sich halt damals noch vorgestellt mit Microsoft Network, MSN, was ja heute eigentlich nur noch als Internet Service Provider oder Portal bekannt ist. Das war ja eigentlich eine eigene Netzwerk Technologie, die antreten sollte gegen CompuServe und gegen AOL. Was auch beide eigene Technologie waren. Also CompuServe war so ein bisschen der Vorreiter. AOL entstand letzten Endes mal wieder aus so einem Projekt, was Apple nicht haben wollte. Bei Apple hieß das vorher eWorld, und dann sind die Jungs halt losgegangen, haben mal eben so einen Medienkonzern gegründet. Und Microsoft wollte halt mitspielen. Und die dachten halt, sie müssten das jetzt genauso machen, und sie erfinden jetzt sozusagen mal das wieder neu, was die anderen jetzt schon gerade so weit gebracht haben, dass es Leute interessiert. Und dann kam irgendwie Internet auf die Überholspuren. Das ist schon so ein bisschen mysteriös, wie das geschehen ist. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht überrascht es mich nicht, denn die Stärke des Internets war immer, dass es auf einer offenen Gesellschaft basiert hat. Also die Entwicklung des Internets aller Technologien bis 1995 war extrem geprägt von einem offenen Kommunikationsmodell, offenen Standards. Da hat keine Firma irgendetwas definiert. Leute haben kleine Textdokumente zusammen geschrieben und gesagt, na ja, hier, das ist ein Request for Comments. Man suchte quasi nach Feedback. Und in dem Maße, wie es dann einfach de facto akzeptiert wurde, hat es sich zu einem Internetstandard gemausert. Aber niemals wurde etwas als ein Internetstandard abgestempelt. Gibt es sowas eigentlich mittlerweile? In dem Sinne gibt es das eigentlich schon. Also es gibt schon Status des Internetstandards, der dann dem RFC im Nachhinein verdienen wird. Ja, das ist dann für so Sachen wie IPv6. Die werden dann irgendwie lange beraten und richtig durchgesetzt haben sie sich immer noch nicht.
Ja, damals. Na ja, wir wurden halt gefragt, wollt ihr Radio machen? Und es war diese Zeit, wir waren im Internet und wir waren nicht mehr ganz alleine, aber noch ziemlich alleine im Internet. Und wir fanden, glaube ich, die Idee gut, weil wir der Meinung waren, dass wir eventuell etwas zu erzählen haben, von dem wir hoffen, dass es noch mehr Leute außer uns gibt da draußen, die sich für das, was wir sagen, interessieren.
Na gut, die hättest du aber auch auf andere Weise erreichen können, oder?
Die hätte man auch auf andere Weise? Na, weiß ich nicht.
Aber es gab halt noch kein Internet.
Du konntest nicht eine Webseite machen, wo alle Leute draufklicken konnten, weil es war keiner im Internet. Wir waren da alleine.
Wir saßen da rum und keiner wollte.
Unser letzter ganz der Madey.
Aber wir hatten eine Vision, denke ich. Wir hatten was zu sagen und wir wollten mal ausprobieren, was passiert, wenn man den Leuten da draußen die Wahrheit sagt. Und... Wessen Wahrheit jetzt? Das gehört zu der Wahrheit dazu. Unter anderem die Erkenntnis, dass es keine Wahrheit gibt und das in Fragestellen der Wahrheit, die einem so täglich vermittelt wird, war uns ja immer anliegen im Chaosradio.
Es gab auch eine grandiose Wahrheitssendung hier im Chaosradio einmal.
Das ist richtig.
Na gut, entweder alle. Alle oder eine, würde ich sagen. Wer es mal nachschlagen will, Chaosradio 23 ist ein bisschen aus der Spur geschlagen, aber da ging es definitiv um die Wahrheit. Oh, es gab eine Sendung, die hieß nur Die Wahrheit. Oh, echt? Kurz nach dem 11. September oder sowas.
Gab es bestimmt.
Und was wirklich passiert ist, Chaosradio 75. Von Ron und Frank. Wir haben ja ein bisschen fleißig und haben ja auch mal alles zusammengesucht, was an Chaosradio-Aufzeichnungen so vorlag, also sowohl Audioaufzeichnungen als auch überhaupt die Themen. Und wir straucheln halt immer noch bei den allerersten zehn Sendungen. Das ist echt schade. Das ist schade, aber es ist einfach...
Das gehört auch dazu.
Wir haben schon so diverse Mail-Archive durchgenudelt, aber damals ging das einfach noch nicht mal. Da gab es ja auch noch keinen Ankündigungsticker, weil einfach niemand hatte das.
Keine Ahnung, unsere Erwartungshaltung war auch nicht besonders groß. Wir fahren da hin und erzählen drei Stunden was, dann fahren wir nach Hause und...
Na, wenn du damals auch einen Mitschnitt haben wolltest, dann musstest du den eben auf eine Bandmaschine machen.
Ja, man hätte einfach nur einen Dat-Tipp mitbringen können. Aber das wissen wir jetzt natürlich auch ein bisschen zu spürt. Egal. So ist es nun mal. Trotzdem ist ja doch einiges Schönes bei rausgekommen.
Ist das so? Also ist der Anspruch, den ihr hattet 1995, erfüllt?
Ich glaube, wir hatten keinen Anspruch. Wir hatten schon den Anspruch, Leuten was zu erzählen und ich denke, das Feedback ist da. Jeder Einzelne da draußen, der irgendwie auf die Idee gekommen ist, seinen Gehirn selber zu benutzen, anstatt das Denken den anderen zu überlassen, das ist ein Gewinn für uns. Und für den hat es sich gelohnt, diese Sendung zu machen. Es gab natürlich auch qualitative Unterschiede. Es gab Sendungen, die waren absolut großartig und grandios. Es gab Sendungen, wo wir nach anderthalb Stunden nichts mehr zu erzählen hatten und dann irgendwie versucht haben, so viel Hörer wie möglich damit zu quälen, unsere Sendung zu füllen. Aber ich glaube, das gehört auch dazu.
Wir haben ein paar Hörerquellen, die Sendung zu füllen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline. Genau, frag uns doch Chaosradio. Ihr seid eingeladen mit uns ein wenig in der Vergangenheit zu schwelben, in Erinnerungen zu lachen, zu weinen, zu lästern und zu loben. 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben nämlich 10 Jahre Chaosradio und 10 Jahre digitale...
Digitale Dekade.
Ja, das ist so wie mit Hell. Wir machen etwas Musik, um Holger ein paar Minuten Gelegenheit zu geben, diese Anspielungen zu verstehen.
0-3-3-1-7-7-1-1-0-D-D-D, das ist so was wie Hell.
Apropos Beteiligung, wir sollten nochmal kurz erwähnen, wir haben natürlich wieder unseren Chat am Start im IRC. irc.3.net ist der Server und der Kanal heißt Chaosradio natürlich.
Namen Patrick? Und? Du bist 22 Jahre alt, das heißt, wann hast du denn dein erstes Chaosradio mal gehört?
Das ist aber auch schon 5 Jahre her. Das ist lange, lange her.
Erinnerst du dich noch ans Thema? Nein.
Nein, das ist... Mein Gott, was in der TLS passiert ist, nicht angefangen haben mit 14, 6k oder 14, 4k ist lange her. Also so 95, 96 sinkt es an. Ich hatte damals so den stellsten Rechner bei mir, 4, 86, 33 Megahertz. Das ist ein geiles Teil. Das Internet, ja, mittlerweile ist es auch irgendwo auch ein bisschen Informationsinhalt. Aus dem Fernsehen kriegt man nicht immer das, was man will und im Internet steht eigentlich teilweise die ungeschönte Wahrheit.
Teilweise. Teilweise steht da auch die ungeschönte Unwahrheit. Also das ist manchmal ganz schwierig.
Es sind mehr Wahrheiten im Internet als im Fernsehen.
Das Internet ist eben so eine Freigeschichte. Du kannst dir in deiner Meinung auch wirklich suchen, wenn du eine hast.
Ja, das ist es eigentlich.
Das ist ja das Problem, du sollst sie da nicht suchen, sondern du sollst es nur hernehmen, um dir eine zu bilden.
Na, das doch auch, aber... Du nimmst unterschiedliche Quellen und bildest dir deine eigene Meinung gleich zusammen, oder nicht?
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein großer Unterschied. Also Radio als Broadcasting und Internet für die Anglisten unter uns, als Narrowcasting, dass es immer enger wird und anstatt immer breiter. Was hast du denn damals gemacht in 1995? Was hast du angerufen?
Also, ich hab da nicht angerufen. Ich hab da Mailboxen gecheckt, also Blödsinn, mehr hab ich nicht gemacht damals. Da war es auch noch richtig teuer, bis ich das noch weiß und dann ging es ja so langsam los.
Entschuldigung mal gerade Patrick, Andreas, geht's?
Ja, kein Problem.
Was machst du da für Geräusche? Was um Himmel zwingt ist das?
Er versucht die alten Zeiten wieder.
Genauso wie früher, weißt du?
Ah, das stimmt.
Pergamentpapier macht ja so komische Geräusche, wenn man drauf schreibt. Patrick, entschuldige, wir sind wieder bei dir. Ich war nur ein wenig irritiert.
Nee, aber ich hab damals Mailboxen angefangen, weil das war damals immer noch richtig teuer. Internet über, keine Ahnung, BTX oder was war das? Zwei Telekom irgendwie.
Ja, Datex J hieß es glaube ich dann. Das Datex jedermann.
Datex P gab es auch noch, ne?
Datex P war davor und dann richtig so mainstream wurde es mit Datex J.
Ja, so auch. Mit der Zeit vergisst man viel aus dem Kopf.
Was ich so irre finde ist, das ist alles erst 10 Jahre her.
Also auch eine unserer großen politischen Forderungen, nicht bezahlbares Internet für jedermann, ist einfach mal Realität geworden. Und das auch noch in breitbandig.
Aber dazwischen lag da noch der Tomorrow Flatrate Betrug. Wann war das eigentlich? 1997?
Das muss Ende der 90.
Lassen wir ihn noch mal kurz ausreden.
Da gab es dann auch so die großen 56k Flatrates von der Telekom. Und hast du nicht gesehen, von was wir anbietern. Und dann haben sie die irgendwann Ende der 90er eingestampft. Und dann kam der DSL. Ganz toll.
Wobei ja manche in Berlin immer noch keinen haben.
Das ist richtig der Ärmerste. Die haben Glasfaser. Mein kleiner wird sich in ein paar Jahren totlachen. Der Papa ging in seinen Anfangszeiten 14, 4k ins Internet.
Irgendwo im Keller hab ich auch noch ein 14, 4er Modem. Das ist noch aus Stahl oder zumindest aus Blech. Also so richtig mit einem richtigen Kippschalter hinten. Der macht Klack, wenn man es einschaltet.
Ah, das war dein erstes Modem?
So ein Highscreen.
Ich hatte einen 300-Baud-Akustik-Copper. Und es wurde mir eingeschafft, ihn nicht einzusetzen, weil die Stasi das nicht mag, wenn man so was am Telefon betreibt.
Moment mal, du hast im Osten einen 300-Baud-Akustik-Copper?
Ja.
Hast du ihn eingesetzt?
Einmal testen, weil es im Osten primis ist.
Wie war es in Bautzen?
So schnell ging das dann doch nicht. Aber dann kamen relativ flott die Wände. Ich musste nicht lange darben. Dann war es auch schon Ende 89.
Obwohl ich das wirklich mal interessant fände. Vielleicht hat ja tatsächlich jemand, der gerade zuhört, Erfahrungen mit Internet im Osten oder es zumindest mal versucht und es tatsächlich eins auf die Finger gekriegt hat.
Dazu gab es eine grandiose Chaosradio-Sendung über Osttechnologie, eine meiner Lieblingssendungen im Archiv. Nummer? Die meinte ich jetzt nicht. Nummer 16, 30. April 1997. Genau, Andreas, da warst du auch mit dabei. Ich nicht, da habe ich mich rausgezogen. Nur die Ostler durften da reiten und Johnny. Und die...
Hier steht Frank, Andreas, Björn, Alex und Johnny.
Ich glaube, Björn hatte eine ausgeprägte Sammlung Alter Ostcomputer.
Es wurde über DDR-Freaking berichtet und sowas.
Ja, ja, alles das gab es.
Lang ist das sehr. Und ich vermisse irgendwie momentan das Einweihlgeräusch, wenn ich mich mit meinem Modem in das Internet einwele.
Ach so, deswegen hörst du dann immer Chaosradio, dass du dann beim Jingle...
Ja, genau.
Da wird ja dein Sentimental. Was ist das eigentlich? Irgendwann gab es dann ein Geräusch, irgendwann hat das Modem ein Geräusch gemacht, das es vorher nicht gemacht hat. Das war ein Peng.
Ja, ja, das es sich dann eingewildert hat.
Nee, aber das war bei den Alten, ich weiß nicht, ob die da irgendwas dran rumgespielt haben.
Das war glaube ich der Übergang von damals, als es von den 28 Modems auf die 56k Modems ging, wo sie das Modulationsverfahren komplett geändert haben und das Einmessen der Verbindung am Anfang funktioniert halt anders.
Das war echt eine schöne Zeit. Da habe ich einen 33k Modem bekommen und dann ging es ja richtig schnell. Da habe ich den Eindruck, es ist nicht schneller geworden. Und ich habe schon einen im Bild.
Bist du denn so was wie ein Stammhörer? So was soll es ja geben.
Eigentlich von Zeit zu Zeit mal. Ich habe mal gehört mit TCPA und Digitale Rechtemanagement. Das habe ich mir mal angehört, weil ich das sehr interessant finde.
Das heißt, du machst das auch themenabhängig, ob du reinhörst oder nicht?
Auch. Also mal Gelegenheit, wenn ich mein Kleiner lässt, dann mache ich das auch. Aber für den letzten 1, 5 bis 2 Jahren geht da gar nichts mehr.
Das ist überhaupt eine interessante Frage. Also finde ich auch persönlich interessant. Was denkst du denn, dein Kind, wie alt ist das?
Der ist monatlich 1, 5 und älter.
1, 5?
Und was wird der denn machen, wenn er in deinem Alter ist?
Der wird bestimmt auch einen 3 GHz Rechner fahren, weil von den Taktraten kommst du nicht mehr weiter. Den holographischen Speicher haben.
Du gehst davon aus, dass er einen Computer benutzt, um ins Internet zu kommen? Oder das, was wir statt dem Internet danach benutzen werden?
Genau. Er wird dazu immer noch einen Rechner benötigen. Er wird das nicht verpflanzt kriegen hoffentlich. Überall werden irgendwelche WLAN-Punkte stehen. Das heißt, dass du dich mit deinem Notebook immer schön einsehen kannst.
Er wird wahrscheinlich schlau genug sein, sich nichts in den Kopf einpflanzen zu lassen.
Wenn er die Option hat. Irgendwann wird das erhofft nicht losgehen.
Du meinst, wir werden dann gezwungen?
Ja, genau. Irgendwie so ein TTIP A-Chip dann zu kriegen, damit wir auch gar nicht geklont werden.
Rechte Management für Gedanken.
Genau.
Weed-Chip wie bei Eric Carter.
Sie hatten da gerade eine Idee. Da liegt leider ein Patent vor.
Bitte vergessen Sie das augenblicklich.
Irgendwie Verbrechen in der Zukunft schon in der Vergangenheit bekämpfen. Wäre auch nicht schlecht, aber glaube ich nicht.
Aber du bist eigentlich eher konservativ, was deine Zukunftsprognosen angeht.
Aber ich denke mal, dass es immer noch mit Kabel gehen wird. Dann sei es mit Glasfaser. Und ich glaube, dass wir dann irgendwann 100 MBit mal als normalen Internetanschluss kriegen oder 2, 4 Gigabit oder noch schneller. Und die Rechner, die werden mittlerweile dann Abwärme von ca. 200 Watt produzieren, allein die Prozessoren. Und dazu kommen dann noch fette Grafikkarten, die NVIDIA momentan. Die Grafikkarte verheizt ja auch schon mal so um die 150 Watt. Also der Stromverbrauch wird auch noch mal ordentlich in die Höhe schießen.
Na ja, wenn das Erdöl alle ist, dann muss man es auch keine Gedanken mehr machen. Dann können wir so einen Rechner nicht mehr betreiben.
Richtig, dann müssen wir irgendwelche Kugelrechner haben. Dann gibt es jetzt irgendwie so einen 100-Dollar-Notebook.
Ja, oder wir lesen Bücher. Bücher?
Du meinst Hardcopies?
Hardcopies.
Danke für deinen Anruf Patrick. Geil für dich.
Gute Nacht, tschüss.
10 Jahre Chaosradio feiern wir im Chaosradio 108 in Blumen auf Fritz.
Ich hätte mir so eine kleine Tröte mit blau und sonnensäu.
Luftschlangen, ne?
Das war ja täuschend echt.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. 0331 7097 110 ist die Nummer, wenn ihr mit uns feiern wollt, wenn ihr über Altes reden wollt, also über 10 Jahre Chaosradio, Altes Sendung, die wir gemacht haben.
Oder auch über Neues. Also wir freuen uns jetzt sowohl über Fragen zu Chaosradio als auch zum Club selber. Oder eben auch zu euren Erfahrungen mit dem Wandel der Zeit. Was habt ihr vor 10 Jahren anders getan, als ihr es heute getan habt? Und wo, glaubt ihr, hat euch Technik so beeinflusst, dass sich euer Leben geändert hat?
So von heute auf morgen vielleicht sogar auch.
0331 7097 110. Hallo Michael.
Ja.
Wartest du darauf, dass wir dir eine Frage stellen oder schaffst du es alleine los zu reden?
Ja, na ja, man kann ja eine große Bandbreite, also CCC, kenn ich ja auch schon aus den 80ern, seinerzeit in Verbindung mit Bildschirmtext. Ich war ja noch einer der Nutzer von diesem System und auch Anbieter in diesem System. Und da gab es ja dann zum Beispiel diesen großen BTX-Hacken.
Anbieter heißt damals konnte auch noch lange nicht jeder mal so eine Webseite, so bloggen oder so.
Naja, es war sowieso, was heißt, konnte nicht jeder, konnte schon jeder, aber es war schon eine recht teure Angelegenheit.
Was hat es damals gekostet?
So eine bundesweite Leitseite. Bundesweit muss man sagen, das waren so diese Leitseiten, die mit 1 bis 7 angefangen haben, eventuell noch 8. Und es gab regionale Leitseiten. Das ganze System bei unterteilt noch im Bereich.
Was hast du damals für eine bundesweite Leitseite bezahlt?
Für eine bundesweite Leitseite habe ich 350 Mark im Monat bezahlt.
Was hast du angeboten?
Das war ein privates BTX Angebot.
Hast du dafür Geld genommen?
Wie hieß denn das? Wie hieß das?
Das war erst Michael's BTX-Ecke und später habe ich das BTX-Service.
Aha, hast du da eine Doku im Web zu?
Nee, im Web sowieso nicht. Also in Sachen BTX habe ich da im Web nichts.
Ich habe noch nicht…
Das BTX hat mir vor 22 Jahren begonnen. 1983 habe ich mir von meinem ersten Ausbildungsgeld einen Computer geholt. Und BTX kam dann eigentlich wenig später offen als Benutzer dazu. Das war dann noch die Anfangszeit, wo man noch eine ganze Menge machen konnte in dem System. Das war noch nur die wilden Zeiten.
Und jetzt hast du ja den BTX-Hack angesprochen vom Club.
Zumindest was du bekanntest, wofür man den CCC schon aus langer Zeit erkennt.
Das war ja so ein bisschen auch der Medienurknall, in dem der CCC eigentlich schlagartig einer größeren Öffentlichkeit bekannt geworden ist. Also vorher gab es vielleicht die eine oder andere Wahrnehmung in irgendwelchen kleineren Zirkeln, aber damit ist mit der Geschichte, ist ja dann der Club direkt in die Tagesschau gehüpft. Sollte man vielleicht noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, was da eigentlich damals passiert ist.
Die Deutsche Bundespost.
Die Deutsche Bundespost hat halt dieses BTX, also auch das muss man vielleicht noch mal erläutern. Sagen wir uns jetzt mal alles so selbstverständlich, Datex J und so weiter. Also es gab einmal, es war einmal vor gar nicht so langer Zeit, als von der Deutschen Bundespost ein Datennetz ausging und dies hieß Bildschirmtest. Bildschirmtext, aber wir haben es immer Bildschirmtest genannt, weil es super war, um den Bildschirm zu testen, aber ansonsten war es eigentlich gar nicht so super.
Sah aus wie Videotext heute noch, nee schlimmer.
Ja, aber ich will gar nicht...
Mit dem ZEPT-Standard war es dann schon eigentlich besser. Also angefangen hat es noch einmal mit diesem Prestel-Standard, mit dieser Klettchen-Grafik, aber dann kam der ZEPT-Standard und das war dann schon ganz einstimmig.
Prestel war Englern, ne? Genau, die britannische Variante war Prestel und dann gab es diesen ZEPT-Standard, richtig, und der wurde dann halt eingeführt. Das war immerhin schon mal ein Standard.
Und vor allem dieses Tollermode mit 1200er Empfang und bezogen 75 Centen.
Genau, das war im Prinzip das ADSL der damaligen Zeit.
Das ADSL der 80er, schön.
Wenn ihr euch vorstellt, wie ich meine Seite seinerzeit editiert habe, in diesem Posteditor im Bildschirmtext, da habe ich hier an meinem Mupet gesessen, das ist ein spezielles BTX-Endgerät aus Österreich, oder in Österreich besonders weit verbreitet gewesen und mit dem habe ich dann da über kryptische Tastenkombinationen im Posteditor meine Seite erstellt.
Das ging dann alles nach Stuttgart zur Leitzentrale und wurde im Handbetrieb ausgeliefert.
Als Postwurfsendung.
Also so richtig doof fand ich die Idee nicht, weil im Prinzip haben sie ja schon mal zwei, drei Grundideen vorweggenommen, nämlich dieses Anbieten über visuelle Seiten und das Eingeben von Adressen mit relativ beherrschbaren Kürzeln. Und das ist ja auch im Webbrowser nicht so richtig viel anders.
War das damals nicht anders möglich oder war es der Bundespost damals nicht anders möglich?
Also ich fand schon relativ advanced, vor allem wenn man das mal vergleicht, was es halt sonst noch gab. Sonst gab es eigentlich nur Kommando basierte Mailbox-Systeme.
In Amerika war es eigentlich auch nicht schlecht. Also entweder man hat halt die Seitennummer gewusst, die man eben aufrufen wollte, oder man konnte ja auch mit bestimmten Stichworten suchen, zum Beispiel btx-Ecke, wenn man so was eingegangen hat.
Stern CCC Raute ging, glaube ich, auch, oder? Also ich sehe, wir müssen dringend eine Sendung zum Thema Bildschirmtext machen. Na sicher, da schreien ja sicherlich alle danach. Das wurde ja nun mittlerweile auch abgeschaltet. Das ist auch erst vor einigen Jahren abgeschaltet worden. Ich glaube, vor fünf Jahren oder so, steht bestimmt in der Wikipedia.
Also irgendwann, naja, BTX war bei mir als erstes, dann kam eigentlich so die Mailbox-Zeit mit Fidunet und so weiter.
Da sind wir aber immer noch weit vor 1995, wo ist das erste Chaosradio?
Wir bewegen uns definitiv hier noch im Morast der 80er.
Also naja, Fidunet hab ich persönlich zumindest erst ab den 90er gemacht.
Das stimmt, das ging Anfang der 90er richtig los, weil da konnte man auch...
Ab Mitte der 90er, da hab ich dann eigentlich so angefangen mit Internet. Wobei ich meine Mailbox extra aber auch erst Anfang 99 abgeschaltet habe.
So, Andreas ist auch wieder da, der hat den Papyrus gelesen.
Ja, ich wollte noch mal kurz, was du angerissen hast, wollte ich noch mal kurz erläutern. Also dieser BTX Hack, der ist ja relativ weit rumgegangen und war ja auch für das eine oder andere Medienereignis dann...
Ich wollte mal kurz erzählen, was dieser BTX Hack eigentlich war, weil so im Detail kann ich das ja nun auch nicht erzählen.
Ich glaube, Tim hatte genau das gerade vor, als du ihn unterbrochen hast, oder?
Ja, ja, ich kann das mal machen, soweit ich... Ich war ja selber nicht dabei.
Ich muss eben sagen, wie die Sendung heißt, hat das Ganze einen professionellen Anstrich. Chaosradio 108.
Der BTX Hack.
Jetzt hätt ich gern noch so eine Digitalkerze. Ja. Der BTX Hack.
Das letzte was wir noch nicht lösen. Mal ansagen.
Also was ist geschehen? Der CCC hat sich wie der Michael mit BTX angetreundet und selber auch eine Seite zum Angebot gemacht. Eine davon war kostenpflichtig. Wie hieß noch gleich dieses Spiel, was Steffen da mal gehackt hat? Also auf jeden Fall konnte man... Pesthörnchen abschießen. Pesthörnchen abschießen mit dem Chaos Mobile. Das war so ein Space Invader ähnliches Spiel. Genau, das hat einen ganz putzigen Namen. Fällt mir gerade nicht ein. Dann gab es noch eine Seite. Im BTX war es gegenüber dem Internet sehr fortschrittlich. Man konnte ja auch problemlos darüber eine Zahlung tätigen. Man konnte so Dinge kaufen. Dann gab es ein definiertes...
Das, was es heute mit dem Handy immer noch nicht gibt.
Na ja, also...
mit 19 abnehmen mit 2.
Genau, ganz genau. Mit einfachen Zahlen kurz. Und der maximale Preis, den man nehmen konnte für eine Seite, war 9, 99 Mark. Mehr ging halt nicht, weil sie wahrscheinlich nur drei Stellen vorgesehen haben. Sie konnten sich auch nicht vorstellen, dass irgendwas mal mehr wert sein sollte. Aber das reichte halt schon um etwas Schabernack.
Ich glaube, ganz in der Anfangswelt waren es mal 99. Finde ich maximal. Vorstellbar.
Ja, aber zur Zeit des BTX-Expans definitiv 9, 99 Mark. Und die Seite vom Chaos Computer Club, die Spendenseite, kostete 9, 97 Mark. Aus dem Grund, weil 997 die größte Primzahl unter 1000 ist. Das hatte man sich dann so zurechtgelegt. Ja, und man war ja selber Anbieter in dem System. Und nach einiger Zeit hat man dann auch angefangen mit dem System zu spielen und auch zu gucken, was es dann auch gab. An dieser Stelle streiten wir den Bereich der Mythen. Auf jeden Fall kam man über einen Fehler des BTX-Systems an ein Passwort der Hamburger Sparkasse, der Haspa.
Zu dem Fehler, ich weiß es nicht 100%ig, aber soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, war das ein Buffer-Overflow-Problem.
Ein Buffer-Überlauf in dem Editor. Das ist zumindest eine der Legenden. Das ist eine häufig geäußerte Legende.
Und die wohl, also es gab keinen Exploit in dem Sinne, dass man da Code ausgeführt und ejectet hätte, sondern es war einfach quasi ein Information Disclosure. Da wurde ein String ausgegeben.
Kannst du eigentlich auch auf Deutsch, was du da gerade machst?
Das System hat unaufgefordert eine Informationpreis gegeben, die sie eigentlich nicht preisgeben sollte. Es hört sich schon auf dem Bildschirm müll. Und in diesem Müll war das Passwort. Ich halte das auch für absolut plausibel. Also das kann einfach sehr gut sein.
Das klingt technisch plausibel, weil es wohl so war, dass man den Editor komplett vollschreiben musste. Es waren nur 4096 bytes und sie hatten einen Buffer von 4096 bytes reserviert. Und da kommt aber noch so eine Null dazu, die den String abschließt. Und bei der Wiederausgabe der Seite war es dann so, dass er diese 4096 Zeichen dargestellt hat. Und dann kam irgendein anderer Datenbereich, wo dann auch das Passwort drin stand. Und das Null byte fehlte, aber das wurde dann nicht mehr mit reinkopiert und dann hatte er fröhlich den Rest des Speichers weiter und weiter ausgegeben.
Aber gerade das Passwort war Zufall.
Das war Zufall, das war eine glückliche Fügung. Vor allem, wenn man sich anschaut, was dann eben die Reaktion war. Also man hat dann beschlossen, das zu nutzen. Und indem man einfach die Maschine dazu bringt, die Seite des CCC, also jene 9 Mark 97 teure Seite, mehrfach abzurufen. Und damit dieses Mehrfach auch eine gewisse Aussagekraft hat, wurde so ein kleiner Apparat gebaut, der ein komplettes Wochenende lang auf Return drückte. Also es war so eine Roboterartige Installation, die halt die ganze Zeit klack, klack, klack auf Return drückte. Und dazu führte, dass diese Seite immer wieder aufgerufen wurde. Programmiert natürlich in der damaligen Standardprogrammier-Sprache BASIC.
Genau.
Man muss noch dazu sagen, seinerzeit lustigerweise konnte man das zum Beispiel auf der Funk-Ausstellung an diesen BTX Terminals, die dann so fürs Publikum da verfügbar waren, bei dem einen oder anderen Anbieter, dann auch lustig diese kostenpflichtigen Seiten abrufen.
Richtig, das ging damals im CCC unter dem Stichwort Jugendförderung. Aber diese Förderung war natürlich jetzt ganz besonders, weil das war halt sozusagen eine Medienförderung für den CCC. Selbstverständlich, also das hätte, also hätte man niemanden irgendetwas gesagt, dann wäre sicherlich oder naja vielleicht wäre dann irgendwann auch mal irgendwas passiert, aber es hätte wahrscheinlich sehr lange gedauert. Also bevor auch jemand nur irgendwie im geringsten irgendetwas geahnt hat, ging halt der Club mit dieser Nachricht, dieses Anführungsstriche Bankraubs, der ja nicht sozusagen das Ausrauben einer Bank war, sondern naja, also die Bank hat sich ja sozusagen selbst beraubt, ohne es zu wissen, aber trotzdem wurde das in der Öffentlichkeit so wahrgenommen, dass einfach das Geld floss von der Bank zu den Hackern und hat natürlich dann auch wieder mal die Legenden dort entsprechend angereichert. Also die theoretische Gesamtbeute damals Betrug nach einer Nacht durchlaufen lassen von dieser Spendenseite etwa 135.000 DM. Und die Medien haben dann halt auch entsprechend die Hacker als Robin Hood im Datenwald und ähnliches gefeiert. Das war schon mal ein ganz gutes Standing. In anderen Ländern hat das übrigens nicht so gut geklappt. Da haben sich Hacker lange Zeit immer noch mit kriminellen Image umschlagen müssen.
Gab es damals keinen Ärger? So gar nicht?
Nee, es gab keinen Ärger, weil das einfach gut aufbereitet wurde. Man ging halt an die Medien und hat gesagt, wir finden Sicherheitslücken, hier ist das Geld wieder, wir wollen es gar nicht haben. Und Telekommunikation erfordert Sicherheitsüberprüfungen. Telekommunikation kann auch Auswirkungen haben.
So wie es das Thema Online-Banking ist, ist es sicher immer noch akut, was?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Sie haben doch nichts gelernt.
Nichts?
Sie haben in 20 Jahren nichts gelernt.
Sie haben schon etwas daraus gelernt, weil zwei Jahre danach haben Sie das, was da geschehen ist, strafbar gemacht. Das war natürlich auch eine interessante Spätauswirkung. Das hat letztlich auch dazu geführt, dass der Club ein Verein wurde, um einfach mal eine rechtliche Person zu haben.
Keine kriminelle Vereinigung, die irgendwo im...
Genau, es hat natürlich auch ein paar andere Vorteile. So richtig vereins- und bürokratiefreundlich ist der Club eigentlich nicht. Wir halten eigentlich auch die gesamte innere Struktur, die ist sehr unausgeprägt. Mehr als das rechtlich Notwendige gibt es nicht.
Vielen Dank für deine Stichworte, Michael.
Ja, das war ja eigentlich gar nicht mal das Hauptstichwort.
Ja, aber trotzdem danke.
Wenn du meldet, hat mich Michael, eigentlich mal wegen der Chaosradio 62 Sendung, weil das ist so meine persönliche Bezug zum Chaosradio. Chaosradio 62 vom DEMO am 27.06.2002.
Die DEMO-Szene, ich erinnere mich genau.
Mit Thadoniel, mir, meiner Persönlichkeit und Rayfinder von der Gruppe Fahrbranche.
Die DEMO-Szene, das kennt heute auch keiner mehr, oder?
Das kennen eigentlich eher immer mehr, würde ich mal so sagen. Weil die DEMO-Szene oder Teil der DEMO-Szene versuchen halt ihre Produkte auch auf Art-Festivals zu zeigen.
Hat das irgendwelche Auswirkungen gehabt auf die DEMO-Szene, die Sendung über die DEMO-Szene? Also Auswirkungen, die du mitbekommen hast?
Ja, also, jein. Persönlich hat man vielleicht mal die ein oder andere Rückfrage bekommen oder mal so Kommentare, gut gemacht für die Sendung oder so. Aber so in der Breite eigentlich, so direkt für mich spürt man eigentlich nicht.
Was für Auswirkungen hättest du dir denn gewünscht? Also aus irgendeinem Grund bist du ja hingegangen, also aus irgendeinem Grund hast du ja mitgemacht bei dieser Sendung.
Ja, sicherlich. Also da meine, also erstmal, einfach weil die DEMO-Szene als solches eine interessante Szene ist, aber natürlich auch, DEMO's kann man ja nun mal nicht im Radio zeigen, um halt einfach mal die Musik, die in der DEMO-Szene so läuft, gespielt wird, vorgestellt wird, gemacht wird, wie man es auch immer bezeichnen will, ins Radio zu bringen. Das war eigentlich auch so eine Intention von mir.
Meine ersten Erfahrungen mit freier Musik waren ja auch Tracks aus DEMO's, die in den späten 80ern, frühen 90ern in Mailboxen kreisten, die teilweise so funktionieren, wie Open Source Musik heute. Jemand hat irgendeinen Track runtergeladen, in den Tracker geworfen, dran rumgespielt und wieder hochgeladen und so weiter und so fort. Find ich auch interessant. Das ist sicherlich auch eine der Szenen, wo kulturelle Anregungen hergekommen sind.
Für mich wäre es eigentlich immer noch ein Ziel, diese Chaosradio Sendung ist ja nach wie vor die einzige Sendung, wo diese Musik mal im breiten Publikum bekannt gemacht wurde. Weil in den drei Stunden lief ja nur Demo-Szenemusik. Ausweite von dem, was ich mitgebracht habe. Und Ray Fine hat seine eigenen Tracks, so eine Trends-Sachen gespielt. Und ansonsten halt, ja, ist halt so ein Wunsch. Wahrscheinlich würde er sich nie erfüllen haben, dass man in einem Radio so eine regelmäßige Sendung mit so einer Musik eben hätte.
Mach doch selbst. Wer hindert dich?
Tja, finanzieller Aspekt.
Finanzieller Aspekt hindert dich nicht.
Gibt doch jetzt das Internet und Podcasts.
Noch nicht mal das. Es gibt überall Bürgerradio, es gibt offene Kanäle. Niemand hindert dich daran, Radio zu machen und es kostet noch nicht mal was.
Also offene Kanal, wenn du jetzt hier z.B. in Berlin bist, ist das relativ suboptimal. Und hier wird es nicht sein. Letztes Jahr gab es halt mal dieses Reboot-FM-Projekt. Hier ist freie Kulturradio, mal vier, drei Monate. Und da habe ich dann halt fünf Sendungen gemacht. Hat mir relativ Spaß gemacht. Du hast auch nur so aus dem Team enttarnen, halt eine gute Resonanz bekommen. Wenn man da mal so in den Chat gegangen ist, dann warst du mit der einzige Zeit, wo ein paar Leute reingekommen sind in diesen Chat. Also es war schon ganz interessant.
Ja, aber es hindert dich niemand daran, eine eigene Radiosendung zu machen, die zu Podcasten. Das machen viele.
Und Podcast, also wenn man schon so sagt, bei dem Thema ist es neu oder nicht neu, also letztendlich ist das ja nicht wirklich irgendwie, weil es revolutioniert neu ist, eine Radiosendung ins Netz zu stellen.
Ja, das Revolutionäre Neue ist immer...
Es gibt immer so viele neue Namen gegeben.
Das ist ein soziales Phänomen. Wenn Leute anfangen, etwas zu tun, verändert sich was. Nur weil das technisch seit 20 Jahren geht, ist die Revolution noch nicht da. Eine Revolution ist, wenn Leute das machen, und dadurch sich was bewegt.
Also auch Webseiten sind nichts Neues. Die Leute haben immer schon Sachen auf Pergament gedruckt und dann irgendwie verbreitet. So wie Andreas.
Oder wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Handy-TV nimmt, was ist daran neu? Pocket Fernseher hat schon vor 25 Jahren...
Ja, aber jetzt machen es die Leute eben. Michael, danke für deinen Anruf. Hier hört Chaosradio 108. Wir haben 10 Jahre Chaosradio 1995. Da gab es die erste Sendung mit dem Thema Chaos Computer Club. Stichwort Podcasting ist ja nix Neues, aber es findet statt und das seit neuestem. Und so auch mit dem Chaosradio.
Ja, machen wir auch. Gibt's jetzt. Hat man ja letztes Mal schon angekündigt, hat schon ein bisschen Nachfrage bekommen und es hat uns auch gleich ermutigt, dem Chaosradio noch einen kleinen Bruder hinzuzufügen. So nenne ich das jetzt mal. Das heißt zusätzlich zum monatlichen Chaosradio versuchen wir uns jetzt an Chaosradio Express. Das ist quasi einmal die Woche. Das Format ist noch nicht so ganz klar. Also irgendwas zwischen einer Viertelstunde und 30 Minuten, je nach Informationslage und Mitteilungsbedürfnis denke ich mal. Aber ansonsten im ähnlichen Stil. Und das kann man empfangen, indem man sich den Chaosradio Podcast abonniert. Und die Daten dazu findet ihr unter chaosradio.ccc.de Schrägschräg empfangen.html. Da steht auch rechts oben auf der Webseite ganz groß empfangen. Schrägschräg Podcast drauf.
Das findet ihr unter Garantie.
Es gibt ja auch einen Chat hier zu dieser Sendung. Und da werden wir die ganze Zeit aufgefordert, irgendwas zu machen, irgendwas zu sagen. Da können wir natürlich nicht so direkt drauf eingehen. Aber hier wird seit einiger Zeit gemault. Wir sollten so etwas wie eine Hack Top 5 der letzten 10 Jahre machen. Haben wir nicht ganz vorbereitet. Aber wir haben natürlich vorbereitet, was in den letzten 10 Jahren so gelaufen ist im Chaos. Können wir auch später nochmal drauf eingehen. Ja, Hack Top 5, was meinen die denn? Hack Top 5 hätten das hier gesagt. Dark Moon Wolf spricht zu uns. Hack Top 5, was meinst du? Alle Hacks oder meinst du?
Die 5 tollsten.
Ja, ich meine jetzt in Bezug auf CCC oder in Bezug auf überhaupt? Ich meine, das kann lang werden.
Das machen wir dann bei 25 Jahre CCC. Das dürfte doch dann auch in 2 Jahren sein, oder?
25 Jahre. Ja, wir sind schon total Jubiläums überladen. Es gibt fast gar nichts anderes mehr als Jubiläen.
Da gibt es dann goldene Armbanduhr.
Zumal wir ja auch ganz andere Auffassungen von Zahlen haben. Auf der einen Seite feiern wir immer gerne diese Dezimalwelt mit, so wie jetzt gerade. Das versteht ja dann immer jeder, aber ansonsten haben wir es ja eher mit dem Binaire. Da gibt es ja einfach viel mehr Jubiläen. Und das Diskordische nicht zu vergessen. Und die 23.
Ich wollte mal fragen, wann ist denn 23 Jahre CCC?
War schon.
Mist.
Hast du verpasst die Party? Eine grandiose Party, wirklich.
War wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwann um Weihnachten rum, ne? Mist.
Kannst du mal nachgucken unter www.cccde-23.
Ja, wir haben einen Chat zu dieser Sendung, den erreicht ihr.
Hab ich das schon gesagt? Channel Chaos Radio.
Oder er telefoniert mit uns, 0331 70 97 110, so wie Peter aus Pankow. Hallo, Peter.
Hallo.
Was hast du vor 10 Jahren gemacht?
Vor 10 Jahren bin ich noch zur Schule gegangen.
Da kam noch dann relativ zügig, wann waren das 97 oder so was? Schulen ans Netz? Hast du da was von mitgekriegt, Peter, damals?
Ja, das gab es bei uns auch am Gymnasium, ja.
Hat das irgendwas genutzt oder gemacht?
Ja, die sämtliche 7, 8 und 9-Klüsseler konnten sich jahrelang an irgendwelche alten Ego-Shooter, die sich blattern und so weiter, konnten sich daran hochziehen und im Netzwerk sich gegenseitig wegschießen. Bis letztendlich mal irgendwelche Blockaden eingebaut worden sind vom Rektor und so weiter. Konnten auf den von Jost-Porno-Seiten herumsurfen und so weiter und waren am Anfang nicht so...
Schulen ans Netz als Initiative ihrer Bundesregierung.
Es gibt einen grandiosen Text von Max Gold zum Thema Schulen besser nicht ans Netz, wo er dann auch an eine andere fehlgeschlagene Technologieinvestition erinnert, das Sprachlabor.
E-Q-T-E-R-P-T-E Oui.
Also so ähnlich ist das wie hier wie im Studio. Man hat irgendwelche Kopfhörer auf und lange Kabel, aus denen man Brezeln flechten kann und so weiter. Das wurde dann alles zwei Mal benutzt und dann nicht mehr. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist eigentlich aus den Sprachlabors geworden.
Keine Ahnung, ich wollte auch immer mal zum Schulfest meines alten Gymnasiums fahren und gucken, ob im Keller immer noch das Sprachlabor ist. Das war dann hinter den Kunsträumen irgendwo. Na ja, dann wurden da Sperren eingebaut. Habt ihr denn zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt... Also ich meine, wahrscheinlich waren sowieso alle Schüler, hatten alle Schüler schon wesentlich mehr technischen Sachverstand als alle Lehrer, die nur da waren, oder?
Nochmal abgesehen vom Rektor, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Was der Rektor hatte, tatsächlich technischen Sachverstand?
Also jetzt auch im Bereich Mathematik und Physik.
Und als sie dann die Sperren eingebaut haben, habt ihr dann richtig was gemacht mit dem Computer oder war es dann auch uninteressant?
Na ja, Informatik in der Unterrichtszeit ging es dann Richtung Delphi. Also man hat dann schon versucht, ein bisschen was den Kindern beizubringen. Also Grundkenntnis war natürlich basic und so weiter, aber ansonsten nicht so viel.
Wenigstens mal ein bisschen gebohlt für Hausaufgaben oder so, wie man sich das so klassisch vorstellt.
Hausaufgaben gab es auch und dann gab es eben die interessierten Schüler, die sich zu Hause hingesetzt haben und unter anderem dann auch ein Rechnerprogramm hatten. Das war ja das nächste Problem, dass sich manche ja gar keinen Rechner hatten. Und zu Hause sich auch nicht hinsetzen konnten und sich Hausaufgaben machen.
Das war damals noch richtig teuer auch Rechner, ne? Das muss auch 1995 gewesen sein. Da hab ich, ich glaube, eine 1, 3 GB Festplatte in meinem Rechner gehabt. Huuu, haben mich alle beneidigt.
Und du hast dich gefragt, wie soll ich das jemals veröffentlichen?
Peter, seit wann bist du nur bei uns dabei, beim Chaosradio?
Ich muss sagen, ich bin auch eher ein sporadischer Hörer. Und hab gestern nur zufällig davon erfahren, dass es ein 10-jähriges Nubilierung ist.
Warum bist du nur ein sporadischer Hörer? Also wir haben doch einen regelmäßigen Termin.
Also ja, stimmt wohl. Aber ich muss sagen, als ich vorhin vor den Nachrichten gehört hab, von wegen der Gesellschaft nur wenig Angriffsfläche bieten und so weiter, das hat mich dann noch mehr bestärkt. Und eigentlich hab ich gestern nur den Gedanken gehabt, unbedingt mal was loszuwerden. Eine Information, die für mich relativ wichtig gewesen ist und wo ich denke, dass auch andere das durchaus interessieren könnten. Kann ich das wohl eben mal anbringen?
Ich weiß es nicht, was soll das sein?
Also es geht um MP3. Und ich war auf einem Vortrag von einem Physiker und Mediziner. Und der hat, ich hab mal meine Vorstellungen, beziehungsweise meine Beziehungen zu MP3 grundlegend verändert. Also damals war es ja normal, dass jeder sich irgendwelche, ist ja auch heute ein Prinzip noch normal.
Entschuldigung, wann war dieser Vortrag?
Der ist gerade mal zwei Monate her.
Achso, okay, ich dachte wir reden über irgendwas Vergangenes.
Weil es ist ja normal heutzutage auch, da werden ja eben die MP3-Player hinterhergeworfen für 30, 40 Euro. Und jeder lässt sich das ja auch immer noch runter. Und dieser Physiker und Mediziner, für den hat es eben eine ganz andere Beziehung. Also darf ich den jetzt kurz ausholen? Dauert vielleicht zwei Minuten.
Mach mal, mach mal.
Ja, also es geht ja seit einstellen, ist ja spätestens bekannt, dass sich alles auf eine bestimmte Wellennatur begründet.
Kannst du kurz sagen, wie dieser Physiker und Mediziner heißt? Und wo der hingehört? Kannst du ihn einordnen?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Den Namen habe ich leider vergessen. Ich weiß, in welchem Rahmen er arbeitet. Und der kommt auch, glaube ich, aus den Flügen Baden-Duttenberg irgendwo. Also der war nur ein kurzfristiger Besucher, der ihm was vorgestellt hat. Und hat das eigentlich nur am Rande erwähnt, was für mich aber natürlich eine größere Bedeutung hat. Auf jeden Fall ging es ja um die Wellennatur und um Akustik und um Optik. Und wenn wir uns die Menschen mal vorstellen als Wesen, dann ist der ja bestimmt ein Zyklenverworfen und Rhythmen. Nicht nur der Mondphase und den Jahreszeitenrhythmen, sondern auch Sekunden- und Minutenerhythmen innerhalb des Hormonsystems und des Nervensystems. Und wenn wir jetzt Musik hören, dann hat ja beispielsweise Mozarts Klarinettenkonzert eine ganz andere Wirkung als wenn ich mir zwei Stunden lang Stahlwerk am Sonntag anhöre. Weiß man ja, dass es verschiedene Wirkungen hat auf jeden individuell. Und wir wissen auch, dass in der Optik es ja Infrarotbereiche und Ultraviolett-Astralungen gibt, die sich unserer bewussten Wahrnehmung entziehen. Und genau das Gleiche gibt es ja im akustischen Rahmen auch.
Ja, aber doch nicht, wenn du das Signal elektrisch ausgibst. Also da hast du doch einen begrenzten Frequenzbereich.
Das ist richtig, ja. Der Frequenzbereich ist auf jeden Fall begrenzt. Nur kann ja eine Fledermaus beispielsweise trotzdem wesentlich mehr hören als ein Mensch. Und warum es mir jetzt eigentlich geht, ist meines Wissens nach, ist ja bei mp3 so, dass dort bestimmte Frequenzbereiche einfach mal rausgelöscht, rausgenommen werden, damit die ganze Datei kleiner wird. Und letztendlich darf man aber nicht vergessen, dass das Gehören mit einer Information ja umgehen muss. Und wenn ich jetzt nur einen Satz sage, wie ich Haus, dann ist das im Prinzip für mich nicht entschlüsselbar. Weil es kann sein, ich bin im Haus oder ich gehe zum Haus oder was weiß ich. Und genauso ist es mit dieser Information, die da aus der Musik kommt, die hat ja einen Einfluss auf meine Zyklen, auf meine Rhythmen, die ich am Anfang erwähnt hab.
Willst du damit sagen, die Leute, die uns gerade über MP3-Stream hören, sind einer akuten Gesundheitsgefährdung? Die kriegen nur die Hälfte mit.
Nein, die bekommen wohl alles mit, aber es besteht die Möglichkeit, dass Krankheitsfördernde oder Krankheitserzeugende eine Fortsetzung haben.
Das finde ich jetzt aber wirklich eine sehr gewagte Theorie. Was für ein Arzt war das denn?
Wie war es denn ein Arzt? Er war Arzt der Inneren Medizin und hat vorher Politik studiert und ist jetzt auch wieder wissenschaftlicher Arbeiter.
War das eine Hypothese von ihm oder hat er irgendwelche Daten, um das zu belegen?
Er hat ein komplettes Therapiekonzept ausgearbeitet, wo er die...
Das ist nicht die Frage. Hat er Studien gemacht? Hat er eine Theorie aufgestellt? Hat er eine Studie gemacht, um diese Theorie zu beweisen oder zu widerlegen oder irgendwie erzählt er bloß irgendwas?
Er hat auch was vorgestellt. Er hat die Frequenzbereiche von Stimmen aufgenommen von Menschen und hat die dann verglichen... Also das war wesentlich komplizierter. Man muss dann zwei Stunden was erzählen, was er in zehn Stunden erzählen kann. Und er hat letztendlich auch Kurven von Leuten gezeigt, die sieben Stunden am Stück mp3 gehört haben. Und hat dann eben versucht zu sagen, was passieren kann. Es kann sein, dass chronische Leiden innerhalb von sieben Jahren aufbrechen, dass man sich irgendwann eine Apfelallergie kriegt. Das ist bei jedem individuell verschieden, was da passiert. Auf jeden Fall hat es einen Einfluss auf das Hormonsystem und aufs Nährstensystem. Und dagegen kann man sich einfach nicht sträumen.
Es gibt immer einen Funktionellenrahmen. Ist das in irgendeinem seriösen Rahmen mal publiziert worden? Wo hast du diesen Vortrag gehört? Wo war das, wo du den gehört hast?
Er erwähnt, dass in Berlin wohl noch ein größerer Konkret stattgefunden hat, in dem Rahmen. Ich weiß hier aber auch nicht, wie der Name war. Er hat es nur in einem Vortrag vorgeführt für Schüler.
Wie ist das denn mit anderen Encoding-Verfahren? Also OGG oder AAC? Ist das irgendwie genauso schädlich?
Da hat er keine Information. Weil er, wie gesagt, er hat sein Name am Rand, jedenfalls, wie mir eigentlich um seinen Therapiekonzept ging. Oder ging es eben auch um Klang. Und er hat eben auch Farben und so weiter ins Spiel gebracht. Weil es ja alles mehr oder weniger auf Herz und Frequenzen hinausläuft.
Also ich kann das persönlich nicht bestätigen. Ich höre seit Jahren sehr, sehr viel mp3. Und ich fühle mich eigentlich immer noch sehr wohl. Ich bin heute ein bisschen verschnupft.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, du hast jetzt komische Pfeifen in deiner Nase.
Wer weiß?
Ob das nicht damit zusammenhängt?
Das kann natürlich sein, dass ich auf der Fahrt hierhin diesen iPod im Ohr hatte.
Ich würde, glaube ich, mal grundsätzlich skeptisch sein bei Leuten, die versuchen, mir ihr Therapiekonzept zu verkaufen. Also es gibt da draußen jede Menge Wissenschaft, die auch regelmäßig total abgefahrene, interessante Dinge entdeckt, die wir vorher noch nicht so wussten. Und es gibt jede Menge Quacksaber, die so tun, als würden sie Wissenschaft machen, um etwas zu verkaufen. Und für einen Laien, der nicht weiß, wie Wissenschaft funktioniert, sind die nicht auseinanderzuhalten, weil die beide dieselbe Sorte Voodoo machen und irgendwie Kurven zeigen und über Dinge reden. Und es gibt aber Prinzipien, nach denen Wissenschaft funktioniert. Und ich denke, wir werden jetzt nicht abschließend darüber urteilen können, ob es da ein Problem gibt oder nicht. Und also für mich klingt es so, als wenn da bestenfalls tatsächlich ein Zusammenhang zwischen der MP3-Kompression, was da passiert, ist Quantisierung. Das heißt, dass auf bestimmten Frequenzen halt die Frequenz nicht so genau gemessen wird und da so ein bisschen Rauschen reinkommt, was man halt nicht hört. Dass es aber, obwohl man es nicht hört, einen Einfluss auf den Organismus hat. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass so was tatsächlich wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen hat. Ich denke aber, dass, vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht ist es kompletter Bullshit, den er erzählt hat. Das ist auch möglich.
Stopp mal Andreas, warum glaubst du das nicht, Peter? Vor allen Dingen, warum benutzt du das Wort Glaube in diesem Zusammenhang?
Weil, für mich, jeder baut sich in der Realität selbst zusammen. In dem Rahmen, in dem ich mich in den letzten Jahren belesen habe und in dem ich mich zurzeit entwickle, macht das mehr als Sinn.
Aha, warum?
Warum? Weil es sich erstens auf sämtliche Wellenphänomene bezieht und nun mal alles miteinander energetisch vernetzt ist. Das ist für mich mal eine Grundlese.
Das klingt für mich nach esoterischem Voodoo, Entschuldigung.
Du bist aber doch nicht mit mir energetisch vernetzt, Peter. Dann weiss das nach.
Also der Punkt ist, der Punkt ist nur, weil es...
Na gut, aber du gehst ja davon, also wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, gehst du davon aus, dass auch wenn wir aufgelegt haben und diese Sendung vorbei ist, wir weiterhin miteinander energetisch vernetzt sind. Ja, dann wirst du dafür ja sicherlich in irgendwelche Hinweise oder Indizien oder sonst was haben, die über pure Plausibilität oder pure Glauben im religiösen Sinne hinausgehen.
Ja, in der holographischen Theorie kann man das sehr gut beschreiben.
Die holographische Theorie ist was?
Ja, es gibt ja ein Experiment, in dem ein Apfel projiziert wird über mehrere Spiegel und Laser und letztendlich das komplette Apfel des Apfels wieder gespiegelt wird. Und je mehr man von diesem, von, von, von, wenn man einen immer kleineren Teil von dem eigentlichen Apfel beleuchtet, wird trotzdem immer noch der gesamte Apfel holographisch trotzdem erzeugt. Obwohl man nur ein kleines winziges Stückchen von diesem Apfel projiziert. Und wenn man das das gesamte Universum bezieht, heißt es wohl, dass Mikrokosmos, wie Makrokosmos, dass sich das Universum in mir spiegelt, wie ich mich im Universum spiele.
Das mit dem Apfel habe ich nicht verstanden.
Na ja, ich habe das schon verstanden, aber als als als schlüssigen Beweis sehe ich das nicht, aber ich sehe das jetzt mal durchaus als These. Allerdings Chaosradio-Hörer sind natürlich sicher, weil wir haben ja auch ein Stream im OK-Format. Falls ihr also jetzt das Gefühl habt, an digitalen Nahrungsmangel zu leiden, dann solltet ihr vielleicht das Enkoding wechseln.
Also ich wollte damit nicht sagen, dass mp3 grundsätzlich schädlich sind. Es stebt in nur die Möglichkeit. Man muss auch sagen, dass natürlich keine Krankheit monokausal ist. Also es gibt ja immer mehrere Ursachen. Also beim Schnupfen ist es wahrscheinlich nicht nur der mp3-Player, der da Mücken macht, sondern auch der mit der Vitamin C-Aushalt.
Also ich könnte mir auf jeden Fall vorstellen, dass es doch sehr schwierig ist nachzuweisen, dass ausgerechnet ein paar fielende Frequenzen in mp3... Also da ist wahrscheinlich das Hören selber...
Ich könnte mir das vorstellen, dass jemand tatsächlich ernsthaft Wissenschaft betreibt und eine solche Studie macht und dann zum Ergebnis Ja oder Nein kommt. Das ist durchaus plausibel.
Aber das muss man sich halt angucken. Bei einem schlechten Kopfhörer zum Beispiel, also wenn ich einen billigen Kopfhörer kaufe, der nicht das volle Frequenzspektrum abbildet wie die teuren Dinger, die wir jetzt aufhaben, dann müssten Menschen davon ja auch krank werden.
Aber mein Punkt ist, nur weil eine Theorie gut klingt, ist sie noch lange nicht richtig.
Ja, aber das ist ja ohnehin immer das Problem, die meisten Theorien klingen ja nur gut.
Ja, aber es gibt schon Möglichkeiten, Theorien ein Stückchen weit zu bestätigen. Als der erste kam und meinte, wisst ihr Licht, das sind so Teilchen und Wellen, haben die alle gesagt, spinnst du? Dann müsste man ja folgendes Experiment konstruieren können, das kann man sich ja gar nicht vorstellen, dass es dann so rauskommt. Dann haben sie es gebaut, dass es trotzdem so rauskommt, haben irgendwann eingesehen, es gibt diese scheiß Quanten wirklich. Und so ist es halt, wenn du irgendeinen abgefahrenen Effekt hast, kannst du den entweder experimentell verifizieren oder du hast halt irgendwie leere Worte in der Hand, mit denen du nicht arbeiten kannst.
Ja, im Sinne der Aufklärung müssen wir da eigentlich auch tätig werden. Alles muss da auch verifizierbar oder falsifizierbar sein.
Also der Mensch hat bisher über 1000 Beispiele, wo er erfolgreich behandelt hat. Das ist natürlich nur ein Therapiekonzept, genauso wie es ist, wie Akupunktur oder sonst was. Jeder arbeitet ja an seinem Rahmen und in seinem Rahmen waren eben spezifische Frequenzen und Wellen haben dort eben einen Einfluss auf den menschlichen Organismus.
Mag ja alles sein. Es streift nicht so ganz unser Kernthema der Radiosendung. Wir danken dir aber trotzdem für den Beitrag, den haben wir jetzt ausführlich diskutiert. Wir werden das nochmal erweitern und mal schauen, ob wir da in Zukunft den Phänomen mal nachgehen.
Danke Peter, wir müssen Nachrichten machen.
Ja, ich kann, wenn ich noch eben dranbleiben kann, während, also ich wollte den Namen von der Organisation nicht offen sagen, dass mich da jeder drauf stößt.
Ja warum das denn nicht? Ich meine, wenn das so ein revolutionäres Konzept ist, was die sich ausgedacht haben, dann kannst du das doch öffentlich sagen.
Okay, also die Therapie, die uns jetzt heißt, Vita, wie Leben, und S-O-N hinten dran, also Vitason.
Vitason.
Ja, so ist zumindest meine Erinnerung.
Alles klar, gucken wir uns mal an.
Morgen Abend gibt es ein wahres Woodstock des Wissens. Das große Fritz-Kneipen-Quiz-Finale. Diesmal mit Tommy Wosch als Quizmaster.
Das wird eine super Sendung.
Im Wettstreit um den Titel cleverste Kneipe in Berlin und Brandenburg treten an das Oswald im Prenzlauer Berg, das Hemmingways in Frankfurt Oder und der Kuchen Kaiser in Kreuzberg.
Und die beste Kneipe, die wir dann herausfinden, da kommen die Vorboten hin. Eine lustige Band aus Berlin und die spielen dann da ein Spontankonzert.
Und weil es das Kneipen-Quiz-Finale ist, sendet Fritz live und gleichzeitig aus allen drei Kneipen.
Im Radio, da bin eigentlich fast nur ich zu hören, nicht?
Und zwar schon von 19 bis 22 Uhr und im Radio.
2 nach 12.
Nachrichten.
Mit Gerhard Kötterheimrich.
Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat in ihrer ersten Regierungserklärung eine Reformpolitik der kleinen Schritte angekündigt. Die Große Koalition werde zeigen, welche Möglichkeiten es in Deutschland gäbe. Merkel forderte Mut zu Veränderungen. Bundesinnenminister Schäuble hat das Vorhaben verteidigt, Mautdaten für die Verbrechensbekämpfung zu nutzen. Im Bundestag sagte Schäuble, dies könne helfen, schwere Straftaten oder Terroranschläge aufzuklären oder sogar zu verhindern. Die FDP warnte dagegen vor unnötigen Eingriffen in die Grundrechte. Die Vereinten Nationen haben die reichen Industriestaaten um Spenden in Höhe von 4 Milliarden Euro gebeten. Die Summe sei nötig, um das Elend von mehr als 30 Millionen Menschen weltweit zu lindern. Das sagte UN-Generalsekretär Anan in New York. Anan erklärte, in 26 Ländern litten Menschen, ohne dass die Öffentlichkeit dies wahrnehme. Der ehemalige israelische Ministerpräsident Peres hat seinen Austritt aus der Arbeitspartei bekannt gegeben. Er werde jetzt seinen einstigen Rivalen, Ministerpräsident Sharon, im Wahlkampf unterstützen. Nur so könnten Fortschritte im Nahost-Friedensprozess erzielt werden, sagte Peres in Tel Aviv. Hertha BSC hat den vorzeitigen Einzug in die KO-Runde des UEFA-Pokals verpasst. Ich sag mal, die war noch nicht geschafft. Hertha spielte am Abend bei Samptoria Genoa 0-0 unentschieden. Heute Nacht ist es vor allem im Norden noch stark bewölkt und es gibt etwas Schneeregen. Ansonsten klart es langsam auf. Vorsicht, auf den Straßen kann es glatt sein. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus ein und minus vier Grad. Morgen ist es immer mal wieder heiter. Es bleibt trocken dabei. Die Temperaturen steigen auf ein bis drei Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz Stadtautobahn Berlin A103 stehglitzrichtung Schöneberg. Die Auffahrt Wolfenstein Damm Schlossstraße ist nach einem Unfall gesperrt im Moment. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin Mitte, die Strelitzer Straße ist zwischen Wernauer Straße und Rheinsberger Straße bis morgen Abend wegen eines Kraneinsatzes gesperrt. Ansonsten keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt!
Vielen Dank, Gerald Kötter, Heinrich. Vier nach halb zwölf.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5 dann fritzt in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Sehen uns dann bald wieder. Soll ich die Rhythmusmatratze hier mal ein bisschen leiser machen, bevor wir anfangen?
Die Rhythmusmatratze.
Ihr habt Chaosradio 118 Jahre Chaosradio. Genau, das Musikbett sozusagen.
Das Musikbett, die Rhythmusmatrat.
Da wurde gefragt, wo das herkommt. Das ist mal wieder alles. Ich bin an der falschen Mikrofonposition.
Das kommt alles von Starfrausch.ch.
Und wenn ihr anrufen wollt, mit uns ein bisschen über die letzten 10 Jahre, über die Digitale Dekade, über die Digi-dada-dada-dada. Über die Digitale Dekade, mit uns reden wollt, dann ruft an unter 0331 77 97 11 0, denn wir feiern 10-jähriges das Chaosradio. Mario!
Du, also mit dem Apfel habe ich das auch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Weißt du, ich dachte, ich wäre nur do. Also nur ich wäre do. Weil Tim das ja verstanden hat. Tim ist schlauer als ich.
Da gibt es einen Apfel und der wird irgendwie gespiegelt durch ganz viele Spiegel und...
Ja, esoterik.
irgendwie Hologramme und dann wächst irgendwann später mal ein Apfelbaum draus oder wie?
Du, das habe ich auch manchmal, aber sobald die Wirkung vorbei ist, lässt es nach.
Ja, kannst du das mal aufschreiben?
Ok, dein Beitrag.
Genau.
Ja, eine Frage ist, seit wann habt ihr Internet?
Seit wann haben wir Internet?
Meinst du das genau?
Also zu Hause, seit wann ihr so richtig ins Internet gehen könnt?
Wir hier?
Ja, hier, ja.
So jeder Einzelne?
Ja, ne, vielleicht die ganze Redaktion oder so.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Aber Einzelne ist auch nicht schlecht. Ja, wann hattest du denn das erste Mal Internet, Andreas?
Ich hatte mein erstes Internet, also naja nicht richtig. Mir fiel da irgendwie die Passwortliste von einem Uniserver in Stuttgart in die Hand und dann hatte ich da so eine Modem-Einwahl in den Studentenpool, weil ich war ja bloß Schüler und nicht Student und kam nicht ans Internet ran so richtig offiziell. Das muss so 93 gewesen sein, da hab ich meinen ersten Download gemacht, übrigens über eine 100 Megabit Fernverbindung, Barview Forschungsnetzwerk, ja. Es hat zwei Minuten gedauert, das auf den Rechner zu saugen, dann hab ich das mehrere Stunden mit meinem Modem nach Hause gelutscht.
Und das war schon IP?
Das war schon IP, jaja.
Wahrscheinlich mit Linux 01, oder?
Äh, nee, ich glaube, ich habe irgendwie einen, es gab so einen ISDN-Stack unter DOS mit PC TCP, mit dem man dann irgendwie eine PPP-Connection aufbauen konnte. Das klingt ja alles ganz furchtbar. Ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar exotisch und esoterisch. Aber so richtig Internet mit Klicken hatte ich, glaube ich, ab 95. Da ging das so los.
91, glaube ich. Ähnliche Geschichte wie bei dir. War auch so eine Einwahl und da gab es in der Uni Paderborn die Arbeitsgruppe Prozessorentwurf, Prozent. Und das war der Account, der nicht sterben wollte. Da konnte man sich einwählen, natürlich nur nachts, weil die Telefonkosten waren ja so horrendhoch.
Ab 16 Uhr, nee, das war bei mir.
Ab 18 Uhr und dann konnte man da IRC und konnte irgendwie live verfolgen, was die Leute zum Golfkrieg von Präsident Bush geschrieben haben. Zählt Usenet auch schon? Usenet zählt auch so ein bisschen, ne?
Wie hast du dein Usenet gekriegt, aber jetzt sagt nicht über Fido.
Nee, ich hab also mein erster, also Internet ist ja heutzutage, versteht man ja das, was über TCP IP läuft. Also insofern, TCP IP kam bei mir relativ spät, ich glaub, das war 94, weil da hab ich grad so eine, da war ich grad eben oft ein anderthalb Jahr, das war so diese Techno-Zeit.
Wann kam TCP IP eigentlich raus?
Das ist eigentlich schon eine Weile älter, das wurde so 1971 entwickelt, so in den Grundzügen und vegetierte eigentlich 20 Jahre, so in dem universitären Umfeld vor sich hin, wurde halt immer größer, haben immer mehr Leute rechner dran gesteckt. Internet für alle ging glaube ich mit AOL los, oder?
Ich weiß noch, wie die nicht in der Lage waren, 28 Acht zu liefern auf dem Dorf, wo ich gewohnt habe.
Da gibt es auch eine hübsche Geschichte zu, von den Ureinwohnern des Internets, das war halt so früher, da waren halt nicht so viele Leute im Internet und es waren alles Wissenschaftler, ein universitäres Umfeld, Techniker und so, das ging alles sehr zivilisiert zu. Auch hier in Deutschland, es gab weltweit Internet, bis in die späten 80er, frühen 90er rein eigentlich. Einmal im Jahr wurde es schlimm, im Oktober, wenn die ganzen Erstsemester an die Unis kamen und an der Uni dann auch Internet hatten, mussten die erstmal beigebracht kriegen, wie man sich benimmt, wie man vernünftig quotet, wie man ordentlich miteinander umgeht, was ein Flame War ist.
Das war im September.
September, nicht Oktober. Also ich kenne das geflügelte Wort irgendwie vom Oktober 1993.
Ja, ich habe hier aber ein...
The October that never ended.
Ein Programment vor mir liegen.
Ein Programment?
Da steht drauf, eternal September. September 1995. AOL gives its users access to Usenet. Also Usenet, ja, das ist halt jetzt der Punkt irgendwie. Also Usenet ist eigentlich das kulturelle Internet gewesen. Also technisch gesehen, versteht man heute TCP-IP und alles, was da drauf ist, aber das, also E-Mail vor allem und Netnews, das waren ja eigentlich so damals die Kommunikationsdienste, wo sich die Internetkultur entwickelt hat und das gab es auch schon in den 80er Jahren. Wow. Also ich hab 89 Usenet gepolt mit meinem 1200 BPS Modem.
Ach, ich war da echt Spätsünder. Ende 1994 muss das gewesen sein, aber da hatte ich es auch noch nicht zu Hause. Also Ende 94 hatten wir es noch irgendwo. Da hatten wir es damals im Büro stehen. Und das war ganz toll. Und das war noch Windows 3 11. Und mein erstes eigenes war 1995 dann auch.
Aber das Jahr 95 war auf jeden Fall das Jahr, wo man den Leuten nicht mehr erklären musste, was ein Modem ist.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Und da startete Chaos Radio.
Ja, und da hat sich auch keiner mehr bescheuert angeguckt, wenn du gesagt hast, naja, ich sitze da am Computer und mache da was.
Genau. 1995 war auch das Jahr, wo die Filme Das Netz, Missandara Bullock und Hackers mit Angelina Jolie rauskamen. Nie sah sie schärfer aus als in diesem Film. Also es war eigentlich ein gutes Jahr, um mit Chaos Radio anzufangen. Ach ja, und das war das Jahr, wo Kevin Mitnick in den Knast gekommen ist.
Den musst du erklären.
Kevin Mitnick, legendärer Hacker, der dann ja, also der hat halt einige Betrügereien gemacht und ist irgendwann eingeknastet worden, ist dann ohne Verfahren vier Jahre lang festgehalten worden und hat eine Sache von, ja, also eine Solidaritätskampagne Sondergleichen losgetreten. Jede Webseite, die irgendwie defaced wurde, hatte eine Zeit lang dann Free Kevin draufstehen, es gab Aufkleber und so weiter. Da hat sich auf jeden Fall das juristische System nicht richtig mit umbekleckert, dass die Angst vor diesem Hacker so groß war, dass er dann vier Jahre ohne ordentlichen Prozess einfach mal in Untersuchungshaft gehalten wurde.
Heute heißt das Guantanamo, oder?
Ungefähr, ja.
Ja, Mario, wann war dein erstes Chaosradio? Weil darum geht es ja im Chaosradio heute.
Heute? Nein, also gehört habe ich es schon jetzt seit ein paar Monaten, aber ich fand es jetzt auch ganz interessant, was der Kollege davor gesagt hat, dass er es auch jetzt nicht ganz so oft hört. Bei mir ging es darum, dass ich 1995 gehört habe, ich gehört habe zum ersten Mal ins Internet gegangen bin und ich muss jetzt gleich sagen, als 2000 bin ich so mehr oder weniger ausgestiegen, so mit mehr oder weniger allem. Kein Computer mehr, kein Internet mehr, hat mich alles gar nicht mehr interessiert, war gar nicht mehr mein Ding. Aber in den fünf Jahren davor, also es war eine ganz, ganz tolle, interessante Sache. Deutschland war tot Internet-mäßig, also da ging ja gar nichts, wirklich rein gar nichts. Da ist man dann immer nach Amerika gegangen. Yahoo beispielsweise, ganz, ganz tolle Chats und Netzwerke und ach, überhaupt. Ja, die ccc.de-Seite war auch eine ganz, ganz interessante Seite.
Und du bist jetzt Internet-Aussteiger, ja?
Was heißt Aussteiger? Man kommt da nicht drum rum, man muss da nach wie vor noch rein. Aber was ich früher, ich hab C++ programmiert, Html und den ganzen Mist hab ich da angefangen. Aber nee, es war nicht so ganz mein Ding, was ich so in meinem Leben so machen möchte. Und von daher bin ich dann 2000, mit 18 Jahren dann gesagt, nee, ich möchte das anders machen, ja.
Und wovon lebst du jetzt?
Ich bin Student.
Was studierst du?
Regie.
Und da braucht man kein Internet?
Ich sagte doch, ums Internet kommt man nicht drum rum. Aber so wie früher, wie ich es früher betrieben habe, mit wirklich alle Programmiersprachen lernen wollen und überhaupt und sowieso. Nee, das ist es nicht mehr. Und ja, es wird jetzt als bloß noch zur Informationsverwertung genutzt.
Es ist ja auch keiner gezwungen, es zu definieren oder zu designen. Also es geht ja hauptsächlich darum, dass es genutzt wird. Danke Mario.
Ciao.
0331 77 97 110, wir reden eigentlich über 10 Jahre Chaosradio heute hier im Chaosradio, denn das Chaosradio ist 10 Jahre alt geworden in Sendung 108. 0331 77 97 110. Tim, du guckst, als wolltest du was sagen.
Ja, so gucke ich. Sag mal was. Ja, wir haben ja auch andere Einflussnamen. Also wir haben ja auch eine gewisse, was ich eigentlich sehr schön finde, ist, und da kommen wir auch nochmal ganz an den Anfang der Sendung zurück, was so unsere Erwartungshaltung betrifft bezüglich Chaosradio. Ich muss sagen, ich hatte eigentlich auch keine, da ging es mir genauso wie Andreas und war dann eben auch sehr überrascht, als dann doch eigentlich eine ganze Menge passierte. Also das Feedback, was man kriegt, man guckt jetzt, dass wahrscheinlich, also du nimmst es wahrscheinlich auch regelmäßig Feedback wahr, nämlich so auf die Sendung so, aber das war dann schon noch relativ intensiv. Leute fingen auf einmal an, also dass die überhaupt erst mal angerufen haben, das fand ich ja schon mal ganz toll, aber dass auch so E-Mails kamen, Hinweise und so weiter, komplette Archive auch aufgebaut wurden, wo wir dann noch selber gar nicht so weit waren. Und ein paar Ideen haben ganz gut verfangen, zum Beispiel auch hier mit unserer begleitenden Wiki-Seite, auch wenn wir es immer noch nicht geschafft haben, ein dediziertes Chaosradio-Wiki aufzubauen.
Angeblich funktionieren unsere Streams nicht.
Ich habe hier auch so was schon gehört, aber ich kann das nicht bestätigen. Aber wenn vielleicht hier mal unsere feiernden Nerds, in der Marienstraße, die nämlich jetzt gerade auch noch eine kleine Party feiern, im CCCB, wer Lust hat da noch dazu zu stoßen. Sollte dann allerdings auch Mate oder Alkoholiker mitbringen, wurde mir gesagt, ja.
Oder Papyrus.
Oder Papyrus, genau, Pergamentpapier.
Und was zu schreiben da drauf.
Natürlich was zu schreiben, ich meine, was will ich mit Pergament für nichts zu schreiben.
Genau, aber wir haben ja auch noch hier unsere Mitmach-Seite, wie wir das mal genannt haben, und da haben sich ja im Vorfeld schon ein paar Fragen gesammelt, die sind so umfangreich, deswegen können wir die nicht einfach mal links liegen lassen. Soll ich mal?
Fangen wir mal an.
Ja, ich hab ja immer das Problem, dass mir die so von meiner Nahseite das Mikro im Bild ist.
Soll ich's machen?
Ich bin das gewohnt.
Ja, du bist doch so ein Frage-Heini.
Wie entstand eigentlich die Datenschleuder? Nächste Frage. Gibt es eine Art Roadmap, wie sich das Chaosradio auf Fritz weiterentwickeln wird, auch im Hinblick auf die von Tim angekündigten wöchentlichen Kurzausgaben, die in Planung sind und hoffentlich nicht nur iTunes-Nutzern zugutekommen?
Also, die kommen nicht nur iTunes-Nutzern zugutekommen?
Unter besonderer Berücksichtigung der Frau im Karneval.
Wir haben keinen Plan.
Wie es weitergeht mit Chaosradio, naja, keine Ahnung.
Schauen wir mal.
Wir machen das einfach und wir gucken, was passiert.
Wird es einen Rückblick geben, was aus den Themen, die in den vergangenen Sendungen... Vermutlich soll es so was heißen wie, wird es einen Rückblick über die Themen der vergangenen Sendungen geben?
Haben wir so ein bisschen angefangen? Ja, machen wir hier gerade so ein bisschen. Du hast mich gestern ja auch schon mal ein bisschen gebohrt.
Gepiesackt.
Gepiesackt und so und gefragt, ob wir denn irgendwann schon mal total daneben gelegen haben. Also, wir haben bestimmt einige Male total daneben gelegen. Wenn vielleicht nicht auch unbedingt mit allen Themen so an sich. Von der langen Liste von ungefähr 100 notierte Themen ist mir eigentlich nur ein einziges aufgefallen, was so ein bisschen in die Hose gegangen ist, war die Zukunftsvision.
Das war Multicasting.
Die Voraussage, dass Multicast eine Medienrevolution auslösen wird, das hat definitiv nicht stattgefunden.
Das übernimmt Spotcasting jetzt gerade wahrscheinlich.
Naja, da hat man auch immer wieder das Problem, dass wenn man populär ist, man plötzlich Bandbreite braucht und die irgendwie finanzieren muss. Also so ganz funktioniert das immer noch nicht. Das war irgendwie schon mal die Idee, dass Sendung genauso billig ist wie Empfang im Internet. Das ist momentan mit diesen ganzen Medien nicht so, weil alles vom zentralen Server kommt.
Also ich kann doch podcasten, kann ich doch auch im Zweifelsfall über BitTorrent oder sowas.
Also sobald das automatisch integriert und funktioniert da ist, wird das sicherlich so funktionieren.
Kürzlich übrigens mit Apple gesprochen, die haben gesagt, dass wir Podcasts anbieten im iTunes, also im ITMS, das ist im Grunde nichts anderes als PR für das kostenpflichtige Angebot, das wir da haben. Das finde ich ganz interessant.
Hast du bestimmt mit jemand von Apple Deutschland gesprochen?
Ja, natürlich. Die haben keine Ahnung.
Das kann gut sein. Der ist auch nicht müde geworden, zu betonen, wie viele Sachen ist da kostenpflichtig runterzuladen.
Zu Apple Deutschland habe ich eine Geschichte.
Erzähl.
Stand ich mal auf einer Messe, das war, als der iMac eingeführt wurde.
Das ist die Geschichte?
Ja, der Internet Computer. Also Apple entdeckt das Internet. Wir erinnern uns, Step 1, Plugin. Step 2, Get Connected. Step 3, There's no Step 3. Jedenfalls gingen wir dahin und betrachteten diesen Apple Computer und diesem Apple Computer fehlte ein ganz entscheidender Aufdruck auf der Tastatur, nämlich der für das Add. Und jeder, der schon mal eine Mail schreiben wollte, weiß, wie wichtig das Add ist, um so eine Mail zu schreiben.
Dazu muss man sagen, dass das Add damals tatsächlich auf der Tastatur kodiert war, aber man musste dazu Alt-Shift-1 drücken.
Eins? War das nicht N?
Jedenfalls war es möglich, ein Add einzugeben, wenn man wusste, was man tut, aber es war kein Aufdruck da. Wenn man, und an der Stelle wird es echt peinlich, wenn man die Tastenkombination gedrückt hat, die man vom PC kannte, um ein Add zu bekommen, nämlich die Taste rechts neben der Leertaste und das Q, hat man Apple Q gedrückt. Und die frischgeschriebene Mail, weil das mit der Adresse hat man später gemacht, war weg. Und nun ging ich also zu Apple Deutschland und suchte da den Pressesprecher auf und sagte, schönen guten Tag, ich wollte mich mal erkundigen, ich schreib da gerade einen Artikel, sie haben da ja diesen Internetcomputer, da ist kein Add auf der Tastatur. Na ja, und dann hat er ein bisschen rumgedruckst und versucht Ausreden zu finden und irgendwie...
Hat er eine gefunden, irgendwas Plausibles?
Nee, nee, also die Aussage, auf die es irgendwie dann hinaus lief, war irgendwie, na ja, hat kein Add, weil er keins hat. Und ich hab ihn gefragt, ob ich das so zitieren dürfte und der hat genickt.
Doch lustiger war, dass wir dann ganze Herrscharen von Leuten im Stundentakt dahingeschickt haben, die dann immer wieder dieselbe Frage gefragt haben und am Schluss haben sie schon mit den Armen gerudert und, ja, wir hätten das Problem bereits erkannt und wir würden daran arbeiten.
Na, irgendjemand wird sich hinterher dumm und düsselig mit Aufklebern verdient haben, oder?
Nein, es hat dann auch nicht so lange gedauert und sie hatten tatsächlich geschafft, das mal woanders hinzulegen.
Okay, nächste Frage aus der Mitmachseite. Bis 1999 konnte man wegen der enormen Internet- und Telefonkosten, Telefonrechnungen um 500 DM, nur in den Abendstunden oder am Wochenende im Internet surfen, also war die Flatrate wichtiger als DSL. Jetzt kommt die Frage. Wird es bald Hotspots mit der Technologie namens VMAX in deutschen Großstädten geben, trotz Elektrosmog und unverschlüsselter Übertragung der Internetdaten?
Ach, na ja, ich meine, brauchen wir da VMAX, wenn man heutzutage mit einem Laptop rumfährt und mal guckt, was so für Netze offen rumliegen, kann man ja schon fast von einem freien Zugang reden. Also VMAX ist jetzt auch erstmal noch eine ganze Weile lang nicht wirklich ein Thema und deckt auch einen anderen Bedarf ab. Aber wenn wir irgendwie Internet brauchen, oder Alkohol, oder Organ, oder?
Ich glaube, da ging es jetzt auch eher darum, einfach nur zu sagen, dass VMAX Elektrosmog auslöst.
Ich verstehe.
Wenn man dazu noch MP3s hört. Dann hilft dir auch deine Rhythmus.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn du dich drauf liegst, dann geht das wieder. Kupferpyramide drunter, zack, alles wieder in Ordnung. Auf welche Weise werden wir Chaosradio Ausgabe 2...
Er hat sein Hologramm fallen lassen.
Das sieht mir aber nicht aus wie ein Hologramm, was da unter ihm liegt. Auf welche Weise werden wir Chaosradio Ausgabe 2...
Chaosradio 250 wird telepathisch empfangen werden.
Was ist das Thema der Ausgabe 250?
Telepartieempfang leicht gemacht.
Telepartie-Multi-Casting und wie es die Medienlandschaft verändern.
Wann werden die Chaosradio Folgen audioindiziert, in Klammern automatische Phonem-Transkription und Datenbank?
Wenn es einer macht.
Das tut sogar schon jemand. Allerdings kümmern sie sich weniger um Chaosradio, aber es gibt tatsächlich für Podcasts zwei neue Dienste, oder ich glaube es sind sogar drei, die sich Audiophiles schnappen und versuchen darauf, eine Speech-to-Text-Übersetzung zu machen. Eins habe ich gerade vor der Nase, heißt podsinger.com. Was sie sich dabei gedacht haben, ist mir ein bisschen unklar. Also podzinger.com. Meine erste Suche war gleich erfolgreich. Ich habe da nicht reingeklickt und gehört. Ich war mir auch nicht ganz sicher, ob sie wirklich das Audi durchsuchen. Aber es gibt erste Versuche, sowas zu tun.
Was sagt ihr zu den letzten zehn Jahren Chaosradio? Gedanken, Eindrücke, Erlebnisse? Was war das lustigste? Mein bestes Chaosradio-Erlebnis, du hast mal ausgerechnet, wie viele Sendungen ich auf dem Puckel habe. Es waren knapp unter 50. Wo ich mich heute noch drüber kaputtlache, das ist diese Sendung, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es 2000 oder so war. Da ging es dann auch mal wieder um Urheberrecht. M-Quadrat stand hier mit einem T-Shirt, mit einem roten Stern drauf, eine Sowjetkappe auf, mit einem roten Stern drauf und schwadronierte darüber, dass die Amseln, dass es ja wohl nicht anginge, dass die jungen Amseln Geld dafür bezahlen müssten, das Lied ihrer Eltern zu singen. Und damals haben wir noch regelmäßig auf Pergamentpapier geschrieben. Und ich sag mal, kennt ihr das, wenn man zu viel auf Pergamentpapier schreibt und die Feder immer so kratzt, dann versagen irgendwann die Finger den Dienst. Und das hatte ich. Und M² war unstoppable. Das fand ich so lustig. Weil ich es einfach nicht mehr auf die Reihe gekriegt habe, den Regler hochzuschieben, damit sowas passiert hier.
Ging nicht mehr, ne?
Die Details könnt ihr euch dazu im Chaosradio Video anschauen.
Das gibt es auf Chaosradio.ch.
Da gibt es einen schönen Link zum Klicken.
So deins, Tim.
Waren das schon die Fragen?
Schönste Erlebnisse. Chaosradio 23 ist doch erwähnenswert, oder?
Schönste Erlebnisse. Ich fand die Sache in der Wikipediasendung mit deinem Gottartikel total großartig. Das war so schön interaktiv und in Echtzeit. Man hat so richtig gesehen, wie das Heer der Wikipedia-Administration so richtig die Haare zu Berge stand.
Oh Gott, er hat gesagt, wir müssen jetzt Gott töten.
Gott ist doof, heute zu schreiben. Du bist gar nicht gekommen, weil es zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du es gesagt hast, schon jemand anderes für dich getan.
Und es war dann auch ganz schnell wieder weg. Und ich glaube, unsere IP-Adresse hier war dann auch gesperrt für eine halbe Stunde. Also die RBB-IP-Adresse.
Ja, das kann schon sein. Das war Chaosradio 91.
Und wir werden diesen lustigen Moment der Zeitgeschichte nacheignen.
23 war eine außergewöhnliche Sendung. Ich glaube, die 23 sind der Hacker-Kultur tief verwurzelt aufgrund diverser Bücher, Sagen und Mythen, die sich darum drehten, dass ein Schriftsteller in San Francisco zu viel LSD genommen hat oder was auch immer. Und auf jeden Fall ein Buch geschrieben hat, das sicherlich die Hacker-Community sehr beeinflusst hat. Neben dem Anhalter durch die Galaxis, das immer wieder genannt wird, ist das Buch Illuminatus von Robert Anton Wilson oft genannt und die 23 ist in diesem Buch eine magische Zahl. Deswegen war auch für uns die 23 klar, wir müssen da irgendwie eine besondere Sendung machen. Wir können da nicht einfach irgendwas machen, sondern wir müssen da schon etwas Besonderes tun. Da ist dann nicht die normale Belegschaft hingegangen, sondern vier diskordische Gestalten, die drei Stunden lang Radio-Experiment gemacht haben.
Das möchte ich das formulieren.
Ich würde leider nur zwei Stunden aufzeichnen, falls da noch jemand was hat.
Das war damals noch Johnny, war damals im Studio. Wusste er, was ihm blüht, als ihr da eingelaufen seid?
Ne. Wir haben es ihm kurz vorher erzählt, dass es irgendwie alles ein bisschen anders abgeht. Er hat sich da aber super rein gefunden.
Jens, deine schönste Sendung?
Ich bin ja eigentlich gar nicht so richtig im Sektor von dieser Ausstrahlung. So hoffe ich, bin ich auch nicht dabei. Ich war bei drei Sendungen glaube ich bis jetzt dabei. Einmal eine Sendung über die Geschichte der Computerspiele. Das war klein und fein und nett mit Max von Malotki. Dann gab es eine Sendung über Social Software, Social Networks. Ich glaube, da haben wir die Hörer ein bisschen überfordert. Das Thema war noch nicht so richtig in der Masse angelangt.
Ganz frisch war der Orkut damals.
Ganz genau. Und jetzt hier diese Sendung.
Angenommen, du hast nur noch Platz für genau ein Chaosradio auf deinem iPod.
Dann würde ich glaube ich doch die Osttechnologie nehmen.
Die Osttechnologie.
Das ist einfach sehr schön.
Und wenn ihr eine Lieblingssendung habt aus der Vergangenheit, aus den vergangenen zehn Jahren, seid ihr natürlich herzlich eingeladen anzurufen, darüber zu reden. 0331 70 97 110. Axel, altes Haus. Morgen. Ich habe eben den Jungs gesagt, du sammelst diese Computer von einer bestimmten Firma und ich habe vergessen, was das war. Was war das?
Die sollte sogar bei dir auf dem Monitor stehen.
Deck? Nee, das steht bei mir nicht auf dem Monitor.
Dann funktioniert eure Informationsübermittlung nicht richtig. Alles fließt außer der Information.
Und brauchst du noch ein paar alte? Wir haben noch, glaube ich, ein paar rumstehen.
Was, wechseln? Habe ich drei, die reichen mir eigentlich. Die Alphas sind mehr mittlerweile. Aber okay. Nee, mir fiel gerade was zu dem Kollegen von vorhin. Noch einen, der mit seiner Gesundheitsbeeinflussung von MP3. Stell dir vor, ich produziere eine Musik, bei der genau die Frequenzen fehlen, die der MP3-Filter wegrechnen würde. Sprich dir überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Dann wird man davon gesund, oder?
Nee, dann wäre ich also mühelos in der Lage, Musik zu produzieren, die auch ohne durch irgendein Filter gelaufen zu sein, krank macht. Interessante Theorie. Ja, die macht aber mit und ohne Filter krank. Da ist, glaube ich, die Kompressionsrate ziemlich egal, es sei denn, wir komprimieren auf Schluss minus ein Bit, da bin ich ja dafür.
Also ich dachte da gerade an Infraschall. Es gibt ja tatsächlich Forschung mit Infraschallwaffen.
Ja, aber welches System ist das in der Lage, Infraschall wiederzugeben?
Das ist richtig. Also wenn man eine ordentliche Anlage hat, dann kann man sowas. Auch das ist ein Problem.
Also auch richtig gute Boxenhersteller machen im Allgemeinen bei sechten Herzen zu, damit ihnen nicht die Membranen irgendwo anschlagen. Und unter sechten Herzen ist irgendwo im Allgemeinen doch Schluss. Normalerweise Kirchenorgel tiefster Ton sagt man so bei sechten Herzen. Dann sollte man damit auch aufhören. Wenn man das schon in anständiger Lautstärke wiedergeben will, sodass man wirklich auch noch was hört, wird das Elektrizitätswerk nebenan sowieso nervös, weil die Verstärkerleistung dafür ganz schön heftig sein muss.
Das heißt, wenn ich mir eine Infrastahlwaffe bauen muss, muss ich mir eigene Boxen konstruieren?
Musst du auf jeden Fall. Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass auch die Boxen nach unten hin sozusagen einen Hochpassfilter darstellen, und zwar mechanisch. Die Membranen haben irgendwo ein Problem. Ich bin außerdem, reicht die Fläche deiner Membranen normalerweise nicht aus, um Infraschall in der anständigen Intensität wiedergeben zu können.
Aber wie geht man denn dann wieder?
Schalleistung nach unten geht quadratisch mit der Fläche. Und es gibt zwei Varianten, um anständige Schalleistung zu produzieren. Entweder Hub oder Fläche. Fläche ist nicht schlecht, ist aber für eine Waffe ein bisschen ungeeignet. Zumal bei Infraschall man da richtig große Fläche braucht.
Sieht aber bestimmt cool aus, ne?
Na klar, die haben auch noch mal so was gebaut. Das Ding nannte sich Earthquake Simulator. Es war irgendwie eine gigantische Boxenwand. Fläche geht natürlich auch mit vielen, vielen, vielen Systemen, die man parallel schwingen lässt. Vorausgesetzt, man schafft es, dass die wirklich parallel und in Faser schwingen.
Ja, aber Fast Array Ansteuerung ist ein beherrschtes Thema. Das machen sie irgendwie bei Radar mit wesentlich höheren Frequenzen.
Mittlerweile geht so was, ja. Ist auch nicht mehr so die Frage. Die andere Sache ist, du machst anständig Hub. Das geht natürlich auch, aber dann brauchst du irgendwie ein System, das über eine große Fläche entweder ein homogenes Magnetfeld hat oder du hast eine Echtzeitkorrektur, die dir sozusagen die Ansteuerung deines Verstärkers regelt. Ist nicht so trivial. Und bei Infraschall brauchst du für dich auch richtig schale Energien. Also so mit der Batterie aus der Holtentasche dürfte das nicht funktionieren.
Ja, Energiebeschaffung ist ja sowieso immer ein Problem. Kennst du MHD-Generatoren?
Ich nicht. Was ist das?
Ein magneto-hydrodynamischer Generator.
Da gab's mal so einen Kinofilm, wo so ein U-Boot mit angetrieben wurde.
Du meinst Hans for Right October? Ja, genau.
Wasseli, nur ein Ping.
Genau, nur ein Ping Wasseli.
Ja, genau. Ein überins genialer Film. Einer der wenigen Filme, wo der Film besser ist als das Buch aus meiner Sicht. Aber da sind wir jetzt sehr weit weg. MHD-Generatoren basieren von der Grundidee her darauf, dass ich ein Gas ionisiere und dann die Ladung trenne. In ganz kurzen Worten.
Ich glaube, wir müssen ja ganz vorne anfangen. Also irgendwie, es gibt da so Magnetfelder. Und dann gibt es geladene Teilchen. Und wenn man die Magnetfelder durch geladene Teilchen bewegt, wird irgendwie Spannung induziert. Und was man bei MHD-Generatoren zum Beispiel tut, ist einfach eine Feststoffrakete abzubrennen, weil dann kommt hinten irgendwie ganz schnelle Ionen raus, die man durch ein dickes Magnetfeld durchjagt und dann hat man noch ganz, ganz viel mehr Energie, nämlich die Energie der Rakete quasi als Strom.
Und im Prinzip sozusagen das Magnetfeld lenkt dann die positiv geladenen Teilchen zu der einen negativen, zu der anderen Seite und damit habe ich eine Potentialdifferenz, konkret Spannung, und die kann ich, wenn ich das Ding da wieder kurz schließe, zum Strom werden lassen.
Und das ist soweit verkleinert, dass man auch eine portable Waffe draus bauen kann?
Na ja, in der Hosentasche würde ich so ein Ding nicht erfeuern.
Ne, Hosentaschenbröste zu bauen ist auch schwierig.
Die sind relativ aufwändig und das Problem ist, dass ich keine große Umsetzung davon kenne, aber ich bin da nicht ganz auf dem Laufenden. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so etwas gibt. Ich weiß, dass man es an diversen Stellen unter Oberherrschaft des DOA versucht hat. Ich weiß aber nicht, was dabei rausgekommen ist.
Also was man ja tatsächlich in der Tasche tragen kann, was aber bloß einen Puls gibt, ist ein Fluxkompressor.
Du meinst einen Fluxkompensator.
Nein, ein Fluxkompressor. Ich mache tatsächlich keine Witze. Es wird tatsächlich der magnetische Fluss komprimiert dabei. Und zwar durch eine Explosion. Deswegen Fluxkompressor. Ist in der Praxis eine Spule, die eine Windung hat. Also man tut Strom auf die Spule, wartet bis sich ein Magnetfeld aufbaut. Dann hat man einen Kupferrohr in der Mitte und in dem Kupferrohr eine Sprengladung. Wenn man die Sprengladung zündet, dann drückt sich das Kupferrohr an die Spule dran. Und zwar so von links nach rechts. Dadurch wird die Spule kurz geschlossen und zwar sehr, sehr schnell. Man kann die gesamte Energie aus der Spule quasi in 5 Millisekunden entnehmen und bekommt noch die Energie aus dem Sprengstoff dazu. Das kann man tatsächlich in Aktenkoffergröße bauen.
Das ist richtig. Das ist aber ungefähr so wie die Experimente, ein 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Fahrradkondensatorkorb zu schließen.
Dann kommt deutlich mehr Energie raus. Also es reicht aus, wenn man einen handelsüblichen Resonator aus einer Mikrowelle nimmt und einen 2, 4 Gigahertz Impuls erzeugt, um im Umkreis von mehreren Metern sämtliche Halbleiterschichten zu zerstören.
Ich würde sagen, Jens, Tim, wir gehen einen trinken und die Jungs machen hier weiter, oder?
Ja klar, kein Problem.
Der EMP durfte dabei ganz gewaltig sein. Das erinnert mich übrigens an einen netten Versuch, der in der Physik immer so gerne verwendet wurde. Der Thomson-Scher-Spuler oder Thomson-Scher-Ringversuch, wo man sozusagen einen Transformator baut, wo auf der einen Seite viele Wicklungen sind, meist 300, 400. Der Transformator hat einen Weicheisenkern, der guckt so nach oben raus. Auf dem Weicheisenkern tut man dann einen Kupferring drauf. Das ist die Sekundärseite, das hat sozusagen eine Wicklung.
Kurzgeschlossen.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip ein kurzgeschlossener Trafo. Und jetzt schicke ich einen Stromimpuls auf die Primärseite und auf der Sekundärseite wird dann natürlich in dem einen einzigen Kupferring der Strom induziert. Und der ist gigantisch. Und der produziert dann, dank Lorentz und Gesetz, eine Ursache, wo ein Gegensatz das Magnet seit. Und dieser Ring hüpft durch die Gegend und springt wirklich durch die Gegend. Und der springt so heftig durch die Gegend, dass man, wenn man Pech hat, durch den Impulserhaltungsatz den Tisch dicht drunter zerdonnert. Ist mir zweimal passiert bei meinen physikalischen Experimenten. Wir haben dann mal gerechnet, durch die Spule fließen so knapp 10 Kiloampere.
Ich habe nicht viel verstanden. Ich habe nur sehr wenig, fast gar nichts verstanden. Was ich verstanden habe, ist, dass man mit dem Kupferrohr, mit der Sprengung wahnsinnig viel Energie erzeugen kann.
Was mache ich damit?
Die leitest du in einen Magnetron. In einen Magnetron leitest du die rein. Das fängt dann an zu schwingen. Da bekommst du quasi ein Funksignal raus. Da kommen dann so was wie 20, 30, 40, 50 Kilowatt raus. Dann erzeugst du einen sehr kurzen Impuls von sehr hoher Leistung.
Dann hast du Funkstrom.
Das ist eine ganz normale Funkwelle. Das heißt, die kannst du mit ganz normalen Antennen, sie müssen die Leistung abkönnen, kannst du die bündeln. Du kannst so Science-Fiction-mäßige Dinge bauen, mit denen du rumrennen kannst.
Die Leute, die in Einflugschneisen von Flughäfen wohnen, brauchen nicht viel mehr als eine Spule und ein Kupferrohr und ein bisschen Sprengstoff.
Ja, das wäre gar keine so schlechte Idee.
Ja, dann trittst du eben hinterher.
Ja, die andere Idee wäre...
Moment mal, das ist doch mit Baumarktzubehör...
Ja, das Magnetron musst du dir schon irgendwo suchen.
Das Magnetron fällt aus einer Mikrowelle und im Zweifelsfall... Für höhere Leistung muss man dann halt irgendwie so alte Mikrowellenfunkstrecken bei Ebay klicken. Ist übrigens gar nicht so einfach, das zum Sprengen zu kriegen, weil man braucht da so eine geformte Ladung, die halt irgendwie... Das Rohr darf nicht zerreißen und das muss irgendwie das schön von links nach rechts gleichmäßig groß schießen.
Das heißt, bis du es raus hast, wie es funktioniert, hast du keine Hände mehr.
Na ja, du brauchst auch einen relativ brisanten Sprengstoff. Du brauchst einen mit einer sehr, sehr, sehr hohen Explosionsgeschwindigkeit, ich denke mal größer, 8000 Meter pro Sekunde.
Also handelsüblicher Plastik-Sprengstoff tut es. Aber man braucht wohl so 20 Versuche, bis es funktioniert.
Ich bringe euch mal zum Lied.
Ich bin sicher, Junge aus der Zukunft, Plutonium kann man im Jahre 1985 in jeder Apotheke kaufen.
Aber 1955 ist es ein ungleich schwierigeres Unterfangen.
Ist jetzt so eine kurze Impulse heute noch ein richtiges Problem. Und mit der Antenne möchte ich das nie aus der Luft fangen.
Warum hast du nur eigentlich angerufen, Axel?
Aber mir fehlt natürlich noch was ein. Ihr hattet vorhin einen netten logischen Kurzschluss, der mich aber auch klassisch an ein Rechnerproblem erinnert. Nach dem Motto, die 250. Sendung wird telepathisch empfangen und wir berichten darüber, wie man am besten telepathisch empfängt. Das ist ungefähr so wie Keyboard Not Present oder Keyboard Error Press F1 to Continuous.
Die besten Infos über das Internet kriegt man natürlich online.
Ja, genau, richtig.
Ihr werdet lachen, ich habe hier ein Display.
Da guckst du doch mal im Internet nach.
Nein, ich habe hier ein Display. Und zwar ist dieses Display gehört zu dem Ding, was dafür sorgt, dass ich dieses Pult mit den ganzen Reglern und so weiter so definiere, wie ich es haben will.
Richtig.
Und dieses Display, das sieht irgendwie aus wie irgendwas, aber in Wirklichkeit ist darunter ein Windows. Und dann kommt ein Display, da stand irgendwann mal, irgendwas war nicht in Ordnung. Dann war das typische Windows-Meldungsfenster, das ich mit OK bestätigen, also wegklicken konnte. Aber es gibt hier keine Tastatur und es gibt keinen Knopf und es gibt keine Maus. Dieses Ding kannst du nur bedienen, wenn du, ich konnte es nur bedienen, wenn ich das wegklicke, aber ich konnte es nicht wegklicken, weil ich es ja nicht bedienen konnte.
Mir fiel eigentlich so ein zu Geschichte vor 10 Jahren. Vor 10 Jahren war irgendwie bei DECnet, also meiner Lieblingsfirma, wie man mittlerweile ja mitgeht, war Phase 5, DECnet Phase 5, die neue Netzwerklayer eingeführt, die erste und einzige wirklich reale Umsetzung der kompletten ISO Schichten. Die haben das ernst gemeint, die haben wirklich jede einzelne Schicht umgesetzt und mit gigantischem Aufwand das funktionierte. Da konnte man weltweit die Rechnerzeit synchronisieren. Die haben das NTP auch schon mal in einer anderen Art und Weise erfunden. Das funktionierte richtig. Der Zeitstring läuft auch nicht 2036 über, sondern im Jahr 4 Millionen 300 noch irgendwas. Der läuft auch nicht ab 1970, sondern ab 1778, irgendwie 23 November oder so. Ob das mal reicht. Ich glaube, irgendwie so, irgendwie um 1700 noch was war. Und da hat man also einen gigantischen Aufwand gestartet, was nebenbei den Vorteil hatte, die Jungs von DEC in München, die ja nicht ganz in der Nähe von dir in Pullach sitzen, was fällt mir da nebenbei ein, die schafften das dann auch mühelos, dir zu sagen, ja ja, guckt mal nach dem und dem Rechner, der könnte eventuell nicht funktionieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob man heutzutage sowas immer noch so gerne hören würde, wenn mich plötzlich der Hersteller anruft und sagt, hörst du mal zu, auf Ihrem Rechner, der da und da steht, geht das und das nicht.
Wissen tun sie es heute noch, aber anrufen tun sie nicht mehr.
Wissen tun sie es heute noch, und heute rufen sie sich nicht mehr an, erstellen sie, du hast einen scheinerteuren Wartungsvertrag. Ansonsten sammeln sie die Daten nur, man muss ja schließlich für seine Kunden, für die Zukunft, dann auch überlegen, was man da noch alles einbauen will.
Axel, ich danke für deinen Anruf. Also das mit dem handelsüblichen Plastik-Sprengstoff, da müssen wir ja nochmal gesondert rübergehen. Das ist...
Hi, ich bin's. Ich mach grad fünf Sachen nebenbei. Nehmt doch primäres Wasserstoffperoxid. Ist viel billiger, wie im Baumarkt erhältlich.
Also warte, ich brauche einen Kupferrohr, ich brauche primäres Wasserstoffperoxid, eine Spule, eine Mikrowellenherd.
Und einen Hochspannungstransformator und eine Funkenstrecke.
Eltern, bringt eure Kinder in Sicherheit.
Chaosradio ist an.
Und ich brauche Schrott aus alten Flippern, um den Libyern als Atombombe zu verkaufen. Gut, weswegen rufst du an?
Oh Gott, ich hab jetzt, weißte nicht, ich hab eine halbe Stunde zugehört und mir sind so viele Sachen eingefallen. Eigentlich wollte ich nur fragen, welches Format eure Podcasts haben und was sie kosten?
Nichts, sie kosten nichts und das Format ist? Ja, aber das macht krank, das hast du ja eben gelernt.
Genau, ich hab mir auch gerade überlegt, wenn man seine These weiterverfolgt, dass man eigentlich so direkt gesundheitsschädliche MP3s erzeugen kann, wenn man die dann frequenzmäßig invertiert, könnte man die ja als Gesundheits-MP3 in eine Apotheke verkaufen.
Das ist so ein Wellness-Podcast.
So Reinigung-CDs oder so.
Wenn man einmal im Monat dieses MP3 auf seinem iPod abspielt, dann ist der einfach gesünder.
Ja, wenn du meinst. Pass auf, ganz einfach, ich hab da noch was zusätzlich, wo du das gerade sagst. Ich hab 97 von meinem Papi mal eine CD bekommen, da war ich mal so ein bisschen depressiv dabei, 17 und erster Liebeskummer, wie auch immer. Da gab es in der Apotheke zu kaufen so eine riesige Serie von Peter Hübner nennt sich das, Mikrofon, Musiklabor oder sowas, von der Firma Digifarm. Das sind irgendwelche Kirchenklänge und da sind auch so Töne drin, die du irgendwie nicht hörst und die irgendwie deine Seele irgendwie keine Ahnung mitkriegt oder so.
Das ist ein solcher Nepp, alles, das ist echt unglaublich.
Da haben sie doch auch mal in die private Konkurrenz hat doch auch mal behauptet, sie würden jetzt parallel zum normalen Radiosignal das hier ausstrahlen, ein hochfrequentes, nicht mit dem menschlichen Ur hörbares Signal mitsenden, das Mücken vertreibt. Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Tausende und Abertausende Leute, die diesen Schwachsinn gefressen haben.
Dann wollte ich sagen, meine lustigste Sendung war der Teehack. Oder zumindest das Thema, was ihr da gesprochen habt.
Ja, zum Teehack. Oh Gott, welche war denn das nochmal?
Hast du eine grobe Jahreszahl für uns, Uli?
Ja, 1994 war das.
Ich hab mir das ganze Paket vom FTB-Server runtergeladen. Ich weiß es nicht.
Der Teehack war... 2004 natürlich.
Ich hab mich um 10 Jahre vertan.
Die Digitale.
Ich hab, wann war denn das?
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich hab's auf irgendeinen Backup, keine Ahnung.
Na ja, das war... Du hast ja recht. Im September? Ich...
Der Teehack.
War das eine ganze Sendung zum Thema?
Nein.
Nee, das war so zwischendrin irgendwie.
Ja, das glaub ich aber auch.
Wann war denn das?
Der Teehack. Ich kann mich noch entsin... Geht erst mal weiter. Genau.
Ja, einmal, ähm, ja, ich denke mal das Beste sollte man eigentlich zuerst machen. Hab ich vergessen, Entschuldigung, mach ich jetzt. Ähm, ich find euch absolut klasse. Macht weiter so. Und dann hab ich noch ne Anregung. Ich hab mit 15 oder 16 hab ich morgens früh um 4 Uhr ähm, damals Enjoy Radio gesehen im Fernsehen.
Ach stimmt, das war in den 90ern mal unglaublich modern, äh, Mordingshows einfach abzufilmen. Was dazu geführt hat, dass Leute wie ich, die Mordingshows moderiert haben, das hatten wir bei Fritz zum Glück nie, aber auf einmal mussten Mordingshow-Moderatoren ordentlich angezogen, frisiert und rasiert zur Arbeit erscheinen, obwohl wir alle Radio-Gesichter haben.
Also wenn man eh schon gezwungen wird, echt früh am Morgen aufzustehen.
Und dann auch noch irgendwie super Klamotten an, weißt du, weil wir ja so ein Trendradio sind. Bei Fritz ist das glücklicherweise nie passiert, dass sie uns gefilmt haben so groß. Die machen hier Radio, mein Gott. Nein, ach Quatsch. Wenn wir Fernsehen machen wollten, würden wir das tun.
Radio ist auch deshalb ein so super Medium für die Sache, die wir hier machen. Man kann Radio hören und nebenbei hacken. Man kann nicht Fernsehen und nebenbei irgendwas anderes machen. Fernsehen saugt die Aufmerksamkeit und Radio erzeugt die Magie im Kopf und die Finger fließen von alleine über die Testatur.
Ja, ich dachte nur an die anderen Zuschauer, die jetzt nicht bei euch gleich um die Ecke stehen oder sitzen. Ja, dachte ich einfach dann, weil ich weiß nicht, wir seid den einen der Außenstudios oder?
Nein, wir haben keinen Zuschauer. Also wir haben einen Zuschauer.
Wir haben einen Zuschauer und die jungen Damen, die sind nur zufällig dabei, aber die gehört auch zu uns.
Ja, ich komme aus Potsdam und ich habe das öfters mal gesehen, wenn ich da vorbeifahre, dass da Studios offen rein zu gucken sind.
Ja klar, also du kannst dich hier vor die Fenster stellen und gucken natürlich, wenn du am Pferdler vorbeikommst.
Im Wesentlichen popeln wir uns ungestört in der Nasa, also es ist hier nicht wirklich öffentlich, was auch so eine Atmosphäre von so einer Sendung beiträgt. Das, was man sagt, man muss sich dabei wohlfühlen, wenn man etwas sagt, damit man dazu kommt, vernünftige Sachen zu sagen.
Aber zu eurem Pferdner, ich habe da selbst mal gesessen. Also wenn ihr euch sicher fühlt, dann ne, würde ich nicht, ne.
Du hast selbst mal hier bei uns an der Pforte gesessen?
Ich hab was genau da vorne, wo dieser auffahrbare Poller ist.
Und warum sitzt du da jetzt nicht mehr?
Weil die, weil ich das, die Philosophie dieser Firma, die drei Punkte Gang da, das ist nicht so mein, ne.
Die zahlen auch glaube ich richtig schlecht, oder?
Ganz schlecht, ja.
Wie viel zahlen?
Warte mal, das sind zwei Jahre her, ich darf es so überreden. Ich glaube, in meinem Arbeitsvertrag stehen 4, 49 Euro.
Pro Stunde?
Pro Stunde, ja.
Und dafür wird von dir auch erwartet, dass du dich jemandem in den Weg stellst, der hier rein will?
Ja.
Um jeden Preis?
Nein, nicht um jeden Preis. Eigenschutz ist da sehr groß geschrieben. Aber ich sag mal, die Mitarbeiter selbst, die tun mir immer noch leid. Ich kenne immer noch sehr viele von denen. Alleine der Witz bei euch ist ja, ihr sitzt ja im Babelsberger Zentrum. Und ich bin jetzt einfach mal ganz frech. Wenn bei euch ein ganz großes Gewitter ist, dann geht der Föhrtner zur Hauptalarmanlage und macht den Schalter auf Aus.
Da müsste nur jemand mit einer EMP-Waffe, mit handelsüblichen Plastik-Sprengstoff......einen Fluxkompensator. Ich geh gleich mal zu Lidl.
Ah, der T-Hack war während des Love Radios 2004.
Ja, das war Chaosradio 94, glaube ich.
Du erinnerst dich doch da bestimmt noch dran.
Der T-Hack!
Da leuchtet gleich der Pegel-Lampe hier.
Du meinst den T-Hack.
Genau, kann man auch bei Google eingeben, kommt man raus bei www.cdc.de. Einer dieser Hacks, worüber wir noch gar nicht so viel geredet haben.
Ich habe noch eine wichtige Durchsage. Wetter hat angerufen und sagt, auf der Party ist der Rum alle. Es wäre ganz nett, wenn irgendjemand Rum vorbeibringen könnte.
Wir haben die Party noch gar nicht gefeaturet. Also wer Lust hat, noch irgendwie zu 10 Jahre Chaosradio und... Lustig, 10 Jahre GIMP. Das feiern wir nämlich sozusagen in einem. Dazu zu stoßen, der muss unbedingt Rum mitbringen. Marienstraße 11.
Und drumrum.
Und drumrum, genau.
Nee, Rum hab ich grad nicht. Entschuldigung. Ja, eins hab ich noch. Genau. Sendung 251, dann bitte Hackingse Telepartie.
Der Tele-Hack.
Vielen Dank, Uli, und gute Nacht. Ihr hört Chaosradio 108, wir feiern 10-jähriges Chaosradio.
10 Jahre Chaosradio, 10 Jahre GIMP.
Aber andere Leute Köpfe hacken, das machen wir doch schon seit der ersten Sendung, oder?
Aber nur bei Vollmond.
Wie meint ihr die Klasse?
0331 77 97 110, wenn ihr so was Ähnliches machen wollt, wie mit uns feiern hier am Telefon.
Gibt's denn noch Fragen auf dem Zettel?
Fragen auf dem Zettel? Das Team sollte mal auf die vielen Internetignoranten hinweisen, die es noch zum Jahr 2000 gab. So konnte man zum Beispiel kirchliche Infos lange Zeit nicht im Internet finden. Ja und, sag ich, ne?
Ich könnte auch auf die Internetignoranten, die es noch im Jahr 2005 gibt, hinweisen.
Ich kenne Menschen, die wollen gar keine kirchlichen Informationen aus dem Internet.
In Deutschland heißt das ja immer, ich brauche so etwas nicht.
Genau, ich brauche sowas nicht. Außerdem, was soll nur aus den 55-jährigen Computer-Internet-Analphabeten werden? Müssen sie die nächsten 10 Jahre nacharbeiten? Fragezeichen?
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
Okay, nächste Frage. Moment mal, wer ist denn heutzutage immer noch Internetverweigerer, der es eigentlich mal lieber nicht sein sollte?
Ich glaube, die Marktdurchdringung ist relativ hoch, wenn man in gewissen Kreisen zu sagen kriegt.
Ach, das haben einfach nur viele Leute die Chancen da nicht gesehen. Mittlerweile kann man ja auch sinnvolle Sachen damit machen. Meine Mutter kam irgendwann zu mir und meinte, sie braucht einen Computer, damit sie Amazon machen kann. Ja, die will halt nicht TCP, IP, blablabla machen, sondern die will Amazon machen. Da gab es da noch was zu VAU, oder?
Zu VAU gab es auch noch, da kommen wir aber später noch. Könntet ihr bei den Podcasts der Fritz-Sendung vielleicht die Nachrichten rausschneiden? Die sind nach zwei, drei Wochen nicht mehr so megaspannend. Und das spart auch ein paar MB.
Ja, aber nach zwei bis drei Jahren sind die total spannend, weil wenn man erst mal hört, was wir so von uns gegeben haben, und dazu noch die Tagesnachrichten, das fand ich nur ganz lustig, wenn man sich mal so ganz alte Sendungen anhört. Also es geht nichts über Gespräche über Plastiksprengstoff und anschließend irgendwie, was Bundeskanzlerin Merkel dazu meint. Ja, oder Bundeskanzler Kohl.
Warum sind im Podcast Audio- und Videocasts gemischt? Wie kann ich als Audio-only Nutzer dafür sorgen, dass ich nur die Audio-Casts runterlade? Möglichst automatisch, bitte.
Ach ja, na ja, also wenn dann kleint das jetzt. Das mit dem Podcast ist immer noch ein Experiment, aber ich finde das ja schön, dass es so viele Reaktionen drauf gibt. Wir haben da halt auch jetzt mal ein paar Filmchen reingeschmissen und ich denke auch, so ein Podcast-Talk durchaus etwas multimedialer ausgekleidet zu werden, weil dafür ist es halt einfach ein schöner Kanal. Aber wir werden sicherlich, aber jetzt nicht mehr vom Kongress, aber wir werden sicherlich das auch nochmal aufspalten, dass man halt Chaosradio, Express und so weiter alles separat empfangen kann. Vielleicht auch ein Rockcast irgendwie mit Bio-Rinderhack und so.
Mit Gesundheits-MP3-Frequenzen.
Genau, das mit Vau habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden, aber sag mal Tim, hattest du nicht ein Interview mit Vau Holland vorbereitet? Also eins abzuspielen.
Vielleicht sollte man auch erstmal erzählen, wer Vau eigentlich war.
Vau war der einzige Mensch, der es jemals bei mir in eine E-Mail-Signatur geschafft hat.
Ach wirklich?
Und was hast du da festgehalten?
Kultur ist ebenso wenig intuitiv wie Gerätebedienung.
Ja, Vau ist der kurze Name. Eigentlich heißt er ja Herward, Holland, Moritz, aber unter dem Namen kennt ihn keiner. Einfach nur Vau oder Vau Holland ist einer der Gründer des Chaos Computer Clubs und eben über lange Zeit auch eine der sichtbarsten Personen gewesen in der Öffentlichkeit, zumindest in den ersten 10 Jahren.
Auch am BTX-Sack beteiligt gewesen.
Genau. Und war halt lange Zeit unser Alterspräsident, wie wir ihn genannt haben. Das war so eine Rolle, die sozusagen für ihn geschaffen wurde. Und es kam der Hinweis hier doch mal, was von Vau zu spielen. Und was wir haben und was ganz schön Vaus Natur auch rüberbringt. Das ist ein Interview. Du erwähnt, dass er zwischenzeitlich verstorben ist. Im Jahr 2001. Das heißt, viele Leute werden ihn gar nicht mehr live erleben können. Also alle werden ihn nicht mehr erleben können. Aber viele haben ihn auch gar nicht erlebt. Vau ist gestorben, 2001. Ganz unerwartet, kurz bevor er 50 Jahre alt werden konnte. Und das war natürlich ein großer Verlust von uns. Es gibt auch Chaosradiosendungen, wo er mitgemacht hat. Chaosradio 53, Chaosradio 36, 31, 28, schon ein paar Mal dabei. Das lohnt sich sicherlich nochmal nachzuschlagen. Das, was ich jetzt hier habe, ist ein Interview mit Vau, was gemacht wurde auf unserem ersten Camp 1999. Das heißt, das bezieht sich jetzt hier auch auf das Camp. Das wird man dann aber auch merken. Und er blickt halt auch ein bisschen zurück.
Soll ich mal abspielen?
Bitte.
Okay, ich hoffe, das funktioniert jetzt hier so, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Aber ich denke, es sollte.
Ich habe mich erinnert an 1980. Da waren wir eingeladen in Mainz auf dem Open-O Festival. Da hatten wir als Platz eine Garage, die nannte sich Techno Shoppen. Und da war ein Telefonanschluss mit Akustikkoppler, 300 Bit pro Sekunde drin. Heute haben wir die ungefähr 100.000-fache Verbindungskapazität. Aber das meiste lief auf dem Netz. Und das ganze Camp ist selbst organisiert. Also das hätte ich mir damals nicht träumen lassen. Und ich sage, der Chaos Computer Club ist 18, volljährig 1983, 1999. Da oben ist das alte Postlogo am Turm noch angebracht worden. Und auch die Zusammenarbeit mit denen, die uns hier unterstützt haben, ist einfach gut gelaufen. Kleiner UKW-Sender, der dort hinten steht. Eine 10 Watt UKW, gerade ausreichend hier für die nähere Umgebung. Und auch das ist relativ formlos, problemlos gelaufen. Früher war so, da waren wir bei der Documenta und hat einfach gesendet. Als das noch nicht möglich war.
Und heute läuft es relativ locker. Die Sturm-
und Drangphase ist bei denen, die sich als Grippkiddies betätigen, viel, viel heftiger. Und da muss man mal gucken, wie man das konstruktiv lenken kann. Also was mir am Club ein wichtiger Begriff ist, vom Spieltrieb zur Wissbegier das zu erreichen. Und da freue ich mich, dass auf der einen Seite viele Junge hier aufgetaucht sind. Und auf der anderen Seite sieht man doch auch eine ganze Reihe von Grau-Bärten hier. Also die Generation von unten bis oben ist durch. Und ja. Wir haben eine ganze Menge einfach nicht erreicht, wenn ich zurückschaue. Und gerade im ganzen Schul- und Bildungsbereich ist da viel zu tun. Wenn ich überlege, dass die Kinder in England schon 1984 in der ersten Klasse Computerunterricht haben, dann führt das 1999 dazu, dass bei denen, die unter 18 sind und das Internet benutzen, mehr als 50 Prozent Mädchen sind. Das heißt, so wie im Durchschnitt der Gesellschaft. Hier ist in der letzten Regierungsperiode oder in den letzten 16 Jahren im Verhältnis dort nichts passiert. Und ich engagiere mich in Thüringen, dass wenigstens die zehnte bis zwölfte Klasse, dass dort die fitten Schüler den Schulserver betreuen, den installieren, sich drum kümmern. Wenn da was nicht funktioniert, kriegen sie Druck. Von allen, die keine Mail kriegen, das geht sofort. Und dass das wenigstens als Leistungsfach Informatik mal anerkannt wird. Das sind die Probleme, mit denen ich mich 1999 rumschlage. Und da gibt es, wenn ich mir den Club anschaue, da gibt es ungeheuer viel zu tun. Und da ist die Generation, die jetzt so ab 14 hier reinschneit und mitmacht, die betreuen dann die Schulserver als einen Aspekt und versuchen, bestimmte Ideen von unten in die Schulen reinzutragen, in die Gesellschaft, damit sich oben ein bisschen mehr ändert. Das ist so meine Überlegung. Wir haben hier die Rakete, die wieder starten soll. Und da kommt es dann gelegentlich zu Turbulenzen. Und das sind die Kotzentüten für die Rakete.
Wauholland, wenn ihr was über ihn wissen wollt, was ihr noch nicht wisst, www.wauland.de Vorne S, hinten D.
Und was ist dazwischen?
Fritz präsentiert Sieg. Am 18. Februar 2006. In der Arena Berlin Treto. Gibt.
See it live und im Radio Fritz vom RBB halb eins...
.durcheinander.
Aber es ist ein bisschen......durcheinander. Aber es ist ein bisschen......durcheinander. Aber es ist ein bisschen......durcheinander. Aber es ist ein bisschen......durcheinander. Info Nachrichten mit Gerald Kötter-Henrich. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat in ihrer ersten Regierungserklärung eine Reformpolitik der kleinen Schritte angekündigt. Die Große Koalition werde zeigen, welche Möglichkeiten es in Deutschland gebe. Merkel forderte Mut zu Veränderungen, Holger. Bundesinnenminister Schäuble hat das Vorhaben verteidigt, Mautdaten für die Verbrechensbekämpfung zu nutzen. Im Bundestag sagte Schäuble, dies könne helfen, schwere Straftaten oder Terroranschläge aufzuklären oder sogar zu verhindern. Die FDP warnte dagegen vor unnötigen Eingriffen in die Grundrechte. Die Vereinten Nationen haben die reichen Industriestaaten um Spenden in Höhe von 4 Milliarden Euro gebeten. Diese Summe sei nötig, um das Elend von mehr als 30 Millionen Menschen weltweit zu lindern. Das sagte UN-Generalsekretär Anan in New York. Anan erklärte, in 26 Ländern litten Menschen ohne, dass die Öffentlichkeit dies wahrnehme. Der ehemalige israelische Ministerpräsident Peres hat seinen Austritt aus der Arbeitspartei bekannt gegeben. Er werde jetzt seinen einstigen Rivalen, Ministerpräsident Sharon, im Wahlkampf unterstützen. Nur so könnten Fortschritte im Nahost-Friedensprozess erzielt werden, sagte Peres in Tel Aviv. Hertha BSC hat den vorzeitigen Einzug in die K.O.-Runde des UEFA-Pokals noch nicht geschafft. Hertha spielt am Abend bei Samptoria Genoa 0-0 unentschieden. In der Nacht ist es vor allem im Norden noch stark bewirkt und es gibt etwas Schneeregen, ansonsten klärt es langsam auf. Vorsicht, auf den Straßen kann es glatt sein. Die Tiefstwerte liegen heute Nacht zwischen plus ein und minus vier Grad. Tagsüber ist es dann immer mal wieder heiter und bleibt trocken dabei. Temperaturen steigen auf ein bis drei Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz mit einer Meldung A115, die Alvus statt Auswärtsfunkturm Richtung Dreieck Nutetal. Vorsicht bitte zwischen Samund und Nutetal, da hat es einen Unfall gegeben und der Unfallwagen steht in einer Kurve. Ansonsten keine aktuellen Meldungen. Gute Fahrt.
Zwei Minuten nach halb eins.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
10 Jahre Chaosradio. Bö Fritz ist an, ihr hört den Blue Moon. Und es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat bzw. ja nun fast nicht mehr, aber angefangen hat die Sendung am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Letzte Mittwoch im Monat bedeutet Chaosradio, der Blue Moon mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Gibt es fast jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, nur nicht im Dezember, weil der letzte Mittwoch im Dezember in der Regel auf den Termin fällt, wo auch das Camp, äh der Kongress, super, Dezember Camp, neu Winter Camping mit dem Chaos Computer Club.
Das echte Münsterland-Feeling.
Ja, also nicht im Dezember, im Dezember gibt's kein Chaosradio, weil da der Kongress stattfindet zwischen den Jahren, so auch dieses Jahr.
Aber dafür findet der Kongress statt.
Der sage ich ja, genau, zwischen den Jahren.
Vom 27.
bis zum 29.
Nein, vom 27. bis zum 30.
Weil wir jetzt...
Einen Tag mehr.
Genau, sozusagen mehr Inhalt. Ich habe da schon im Podcast so viel darüber erzählt, aber der Kongress ist und ihr kommt alle.
Und wenn ihr noch ein bisschen mit uns feiern wollt, 031 77 91 1 1 0. Hallo Tobias.
Ah, Tobias, Entschuldigung, kann ich kurz noch was sagen. Also das Interview, Entschuldigung, das Video mit dem Baum, das wir gerade abgespielt haben.
Das werfe ich jetzt mal in den Podcast.
Jetzt, Tobias.
Ja, sag mal, vorhin hatte doch jemand diese Woche, der mit dem Apfel-Hologramm angesprochen hatte.
Ja, hast du das verstanden, weil ich hab's nicht verstanden?
Naja, halbwegs steige ich das schon durch. Aber naja, der hatte doch dann ganz zum Schluss noch diese energetische Vernetzung angesprochen.
Wollen wir das jetzt vertiefen?
Ja, weil ich jetzt gerade eine Chemie-Hausaufgaben...
Eine Chemie-Hausaufgaben?
Schon seit, was hatte ich wie lange ein und dann bin ich drauf gekommen, wie das gemeint haben könnte. Und wie? Energietische Vernetzung läuft ja so, da sind ja alles Wellen. Egal ob Licht, ob Ton, was weiß ich nicht was.
Das sind nach neuestem Stand davor schon nicht alles Wellen.
Das beginnt schon damit, dass wir alle eigentlich Sonnenlicht sehen und damit ähnliche Wellen aufnehmen. Nur diese Wellen geben wir über unsere Sprache, sprich über Akustik, an jemanden anders weiter.
Aber deswegen sind wir doch nicht vernetzt. Wenn wir sagen, wir sind vernetzt, dann geht es doch um Interaktion und die findet nun wirklich nicht statt.
Na ja, das ist nicht das Letzte im Sinne vom Internet, was man aus dem Internet kennt. Ja, halt Millionen, Milliarden von Wellen kreuzen, sag ich mal, die von einem zum anderen gehen und vom anderen Tisch nicht abgefangen werden.
Wenn ich immer so blöd frage, wie ja und? Also ich meine, erstens ist es nicht messbar, damit ist es nicht belegbar. Zweitens, selbst wenn man wohlwollend ist, warum sollte ich glauben, dass es so ist? Also warum sollte ich glauben, dass irgendjemand, der auf der anderen Seite des Erdballs einen Gedanken denkt, warum sollte dieser Gedanke eine unmittelbare oder von mir aus auch eine mittelbare Auswirkung auf mich haben? Also das funktioniert nicht.
Na ja, man soll ja nicht so grobmaschig denken.
Das tun wir ja auch nicht.
Ich denke aber ja grobmaschig, muss man feinmaschig denken, soll ich mal so auf die nähere Umgebung bedacht.
Ja, aber feinmaschig denken heißt ja aber wirklich nicht, wirklich jeden Scheiß durchkauen zu müssen. Das ist doch absurd.
Aber ein bisschen meckern wollte ich ja auch noch. Ja, wir Cottbusser haben nämlich irgendwie ein Problem. Wir kommen zwar an dieses lustige DSL ran, aber die ganzen hübschen kleinen billige Angebote, Cityflat und diese alle heißen, da kommen wir Cottbusser nicht ran.
Ja, das haben wir der Telekom gesagt. Das geht nicht. Cottbus, tut mir leid.
Und vor allem das nächste Ding ist, wir hatten gerade erst eine Sanierung im Blog gehabt und die haben uns Glasfaserkabel-Eggen geboten.
Blog mit CK, ne?
Und die haben uns die ganze Straße lang Glasfaserkabel-Eggen geboten.
Das ist aber nett.
Ja, seitdem kriegen wir das System, kommen wir aber an Candice Elmer ran.
Da freut sich der ganze Friedrichshain in Berlin schon seit Jahren drüber.
Man nennt das das Opal-Ghetto.
Ja, optische Anschlussleitung.
Ja, früher oder später gibt es das, diese Wimax-Geschichte scheint sich doch einigermaßen einer wachsenden Beliebtheit zu erfreuen.
Es gibt halt jetzt Anbieter, die da auf den Markt mitgehen. Ob das erstmal funktioniert, das müssen wir erstmal sehen.
So weit ist man noch nicht.
Aber sie starten halt jetzt gerade. Meine neuen Technologien, muss man halt erstmal gucken. Aber die Telekom hat sich da auf jeden Fall ein ganz schönes Ei gelegt mit diesen optischen Leitungen.
Was ich ganz spannend fand, ich habe irgendwo gelesen, es gibt auch irgendein Dorf, weiß der Geier, wo irgendwo in Westdeutschland, die auch gesagt haben, wir wollen DSL haben. Die Telekom hat immer gesagt, wir sind nicht in der Lage zu liefern. Dann haben die einen Vertrag geschlossen mit so einem Wemax-Anbieter. Und auf einmal hat die Telekom DSL in diesen Ort geliefert. Das ist ja auch ganz praktisch. Tobias, wahrscheinlich musst du einfach nur ein bisschen warten, bis was passiert. Das musste ich auch, denn ich habe auch in Friedrichshain gewohnt.
Ich hab's jetzt anders gemacht. Es gibt doch auch diese DSL-Angebote über die Fernsehantenne.
Glückwunsch.
Also für manche Leute ist auch 2005 noch 1995.
Danke für deinen Anruf, Tobias.
Das nächste Ding ist, wir haben einen Kottbus. Haben die gerade mal...
Ja, es geht ums Chaosradio hier und nicht ums Kottbus. Danke für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Wer wartet länger? Der Patrick wartet länger. Hallo, Patrick aus Hannover. Ja, du bist dran.
Also erst mal herzlichen Glückwunsch zum 10. Und ich freue mich, alle Leute, die da im Studio mitgewirkt haben, gehört zu haben. Das ist wunderbar. Das ist klasse. Man hört sehr viel Information. Und ich freue mich jedes Mal darüber, dass ihr wirklich gute Informationen und nutzbare Informationen liefert. Und das probiert auch an die Leute herauszubringen in Klartext. Also nicht irgendwelche RSS oder was weiß ich Abkürzungen zu stecken, sondern halt jedes Mal das ordentlich in eine gute Verpackung zu packen.
Dankeschön Patrick. Das ist aber auch irgendwie, das muss man auch lernen erst, oder? Habt ihr das von Anfang an gemacht? Ich war ja nicht von Anfang an beim Chaosradio dabei, also muss man auch erstmal lernen, dass du eben immer wieder dich öffnest und sagst, ok, ich muss erklären, was ich hier für Sachen erzähle.
Naja, wir sind doch Hacker. Das ist ja sozusagen Teil dessen, warum wir uns auch so nennen.
Ist es das?
Ja, ist es auf jeden Fall.
Wissensvermittlung ohne Wissen, kannst du nichts machen.
Das ist richtig, aber ich hab doch selbst oft genug erlebt, dass du in deinem Orbit oder in deinem Universum schon irgendwo gefangen bist und annimmst, dass das, was du gerade denkst oder die Art und Weise, wie du dich gerade äußerst, dass das alle verstehen, was dann auch nicht der Fall ist.
Ich denke, wir haben auch immer versucht, eine Balance zu treffen. Auf der einen Seite versucht, Informationen verdichtet drüber zu bringen für die Leute, die es verstehen, wenn man es einfach sagt und uns dann nochmal die Zeit zu nehmen, um nochmal so viele Leute wie möglich mitzunehmen. Johnny hat uns am Anfang auch sehr geholfen. Er hat sich sehr gut in die Rolle dessen, der schon interessiert ist, aber nichts versteht, hineinzuversetzen und die richtigen Fragen zu stellen und diesen Moment zu triggern, dieses Oh, richtig, das ist ja gar nicht selbstverständlich, von dem ich da gerade ausgehe und das von da nochmal aufzurollen.
Es klappt ja auch nicht immer. Manchmal gibt es ja auch einfach so Momente, da wird einfach nur gegeakt. Und für die Leute da draußen könnte das dann einfach nur ein interessantes Geräusch sein.
Es ist ja auch tatsächlich so, es gibt einen Kollegen Spallek, der moderiert die Radio Fritzen am Nachmittag, das war in den Night Flight hier auf Fritz, der sagte auch, im Vorfeld dieser Sendung, er hört sich das oft genug an, versteht für gewöhnlich kein Wort, aber für ihn klingt das insgesamt wie Musik. Also das fand ich ein sehr, sehr schönes Bild. Also er versteht nicht, was wir reden, aber so wie wir es machen, scheint das für ihn zumindest angenehm genug zu sein. Wir begrüßen Sven aus Braunschweig.
Hallo, ich wollte auch mal meinen Dank an euch irgendwie loswerden. Ich glaub, ich hab noch nicht mal geguckt, was die erste Sendung eigentlich war, und ich gehört hab, ich komm nicht mehr wirklich drauf.
Was ist denn die älteste, an die du dich erinnerst?
Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich eine über die D-Box damals noch mitgeschnitten hab, über seit Lead of VHS, weil ich keine Aufnahmemöglichkeiten hatten. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich kein Internet hatte oder das einfach noch auf dem Bezahltarif hinauslief. Das war irgendwie Kryptographie und Privatsphäre, glaube ich, die 34er.
Oh, die hast du noch als Aufzeichnung?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Tape noch habe, aber ich kann mich an das Etikett erinnern. Das war die Folge.
Wir haben das nämlich nicht als Aufzeichnung.
Also ich hab vorher auf jeden Fall schon was im Download gehabt, aber dieses Live-Ritzen, das ging halt gar nicht über Stream.
Deswegen war das über D-Box aufgenommen, weiß ich noch.
Guck doch mal. Also das ist eine, die uns noch fehlt.
Falls du die findest, einfach mal einschicken.
Zählt die wirklich?
Ja, die haben wir nicht im Archiv. Dann guck ich mal. Und die anderen bitte auch mal.
Da gab's vorher noch eine zu dem Themenkomplex.
Ich hab mir jetzt die rausgesucht. Ich hoffe nicht, dass es die andere war.
Na, das war jetzt genau die mit dem Titel, die du gesagt hast. Wir hatten das Thema sicherlich mehr als einmal, aber ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, wie die andere sind.
Also entweder war es die oder die andere.
Ja, es gab mal eine noch zur Public-Krieg-Kryptographie, also wo es mehr um Signieren, Zertifizieren und so weiter geht.
Auch sehr schön fand ich damals die Folge 64 mit dem Thema C64.
Und so habt ihr da Musik aus den Spielen eingespielt mit der Bitte an die Hörer, da mal zu warten.
Und das war richtig groß, fand ich. Moment, die Musik aus den Spielen, das war eine andere Sendung. War die das nicht? Nein, nein, das ist richtig. Da haben wir so C64.
Da fällt mir ein, es gibt so einen wunderbaren Swan-Schnips, den ich neulich gehört habe, und zwar die Mario Brothers Melodie, eingespielt vom London Symphony Orchestra. Das ist so großartig.
Sven, das war's schon?
Nee, ich hab nur eine Frage an dich.
Zurück in die Zukunft, wie oft gesehen?
Ich habe nicht die leiseste Ahnung.
Ich fand das so beeindruckend.
Ich habe wirklich nicht die leiseste Ahnung, wie oft ich diesen Film gesehen habe. Er gehört zu denen, die ich am häufigsten am öftesten sehe. Ich hab den am öftesten gesehen.
Hast du damit eine leichte Cola? Meinst du damit eine leichte Cola?
Genau, einen Kaffee ohne zu bezahlen, so was gibt's hier nicht.
Ja, wie gesagt, super Sendung. Macht weiter so, ich würde mich freuen und ich bleib euch in bestimmte Alten.
Wir bemühen uns. Besten Dank, Sven. Jetzt rufen sie alle an. 0331 77 97 110. Hallo, Reinhard.
Jo, bin ich jetzt auf der Leitung?
Nee, auf Sendung.
Auf Sendung, gut. Einmal finde ich das gut, dass überhaupt eine Radiosendung, so wie ihr, so lange besteht. 10 Jahre.
Das ist echt verblüffend eigentlich.
Punkt eins. Punkt zwei ist, ich bin schon etwas älteres Semester und die Einbauanleitung oder das etwas ausufernde und längere Gespräch über Bomben bauen, ich kann nicht beurteilen, ob das jetzt nun ein Joke war, ob ihr da was geschnupft habt oder nicht. Eine etwas längere Hinauszügung einer gewissen Comedy- Einheit eurer Sendung war, bitte ich doch als Anmerkung, als kritische Anmerkung, eben doch in einer anderen Sendung zu machen. So, den Wunsch oder die Aufmerksamkeit...
Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Reinhard, sag das nochmal. Du bittest das in einer anderen Sendung zu machen?
Ja. Eine Bombenbauanleitung muss nicht gerade in 10 Jahren Chaos Computer Club Berlin sein.
Ach du meinst, wir sollten eine separate Sendung ausschließlich über Bomben basteln machen?
Ich glaube, damit würden wir uns dann aber richtig feinde machen. Wenn du so zufällig drauf kommst, was das ja nur wirklich war...
Ja, kommt ja auf die Bomben an. Man könnte ja zum Beispiel Wasserbomben bauen.
Gibt da ja so einige Geräte oder so.
Eisbomben finde ich lecker.
Man kann auch Kapitänwasser schmeißen.
Damals ist damit gefischt worden.
Echt?
Stimmt Dynamitfischen, ne?
Ja, so ähnlich. Gut, aber ich möchte hier noch gerne zu meinem anregenden Beitrag kommen. Ich würde vorschlagen, oder der Wunsch von mir wäre, noch mal eine aktuelle Übersicht zu bekommen, wenn ihr das machen könntet, über die Abhörung, beziehungsweise über die mangelnde Sicherheit. Es ist ja angeschnitten worden, dass die Daten irgendwie rausgehen vom Computer an gewisse Hersteller. Und im Heiseverlach war, glaube ich, vor kurzem die Mitteilung, dass seit kurzem hardwaremäßige Schutzmechanismen, in Anführungsstrichen, auf Mainboards schon eingebaut werden, es aber nicht publik wird. Wenn es vom Betriebssystem diese Sicherung scharf geschaltet wird, dann könnte man sich vorstellen, dass man in bestimmten Zeitabständen ins Internet muss, damit überprüft werden kann, ist das legal oder nicht. Man weiß nicht, was damit noch alles für Sachen aufwarten wird.
Da haben wir auch, glaube ich, schon länger nicht mehr das Thema.
Du brichst jetzt auf TCP-A an.
TCP-A, ja.
Das hat eine ganze Menge durcheinander.
Das sind ein Haufen Themen, und zu vielen haben wir auch schon Sendung gemacht. Zu vielen wäre es sicherlich wert, auch weiterhin Sendung zu machen. Also irgendwie die Datensammlei hatten wir ja gerade in den Nachrichten. Deswegen ist es sehr sinnvoll, die Nachrichten nicht rauszuschneiden, so als Dokument der Zeitgeschichte. Dass vor wenigen Jahren uns noch versichert wird, ja, das Maus-System, das ist nur irgendwie zum Ja, wir verdienen da Geld und irgendwie, da fallen keine Daten an. Na gut, da fallen doch Daten an, aber wir belöschen sie. Und wir machen auch ein Gesetz. Jetzt stellt sich der Innenminister hin und sagt, ich will die Daten aber doch haben, wegen den bösen Terroristen.
Oh nee, nicht wegen der Terroristen, aber auf Verbrechensaufklärung.
Und ich muss zu Herrn Schilley noch eine Geschichte erzählen. Die muss ich leider noch loswerden, bevor die Sendung los ist.
Du meinst unser neuen Innenminister?
Unser neuer Minister, Schäuble.
Der hat vor ein paar Jahren den Bundestag belogen übrigens. Das haben alle vergessen wieder.
Ja, nicht nur das, ich saß auf einer Veranstaltung am Gendarmenmarkt im Schauspielhaus, hatte der Spiegel geladen, eine Podiumsdiskussion zum Thema. Wie geht das weiter mit unserer Verfassung gemacht? Also es ging um Reform des Föderalismus, solche Geschichten. Da saß halt irgendwie ein Herr Schäuble und eine Frau Däubler-Gmelin und ein Verfassungsrichter und noch so ein, zwei Gestalten. Und da hat der Herr Schäuble gesagt, und zwar wörtlich, es wäre doch beim Regieren sehr hinderlich, dass man zum Ändern der Verfassung sich an die Verfassung halten müsste. Und dem nebendem sitzenden Ex-Verfassungsrichter ist buchstäblich das Essen aus dem Gesicht gefallen. Der hat sich für die Verhältnisse eines emeritierten Verfassungsrichters wirklich eschöpiert darüber. Und so jemand, der einfach unsere Verfassung missachtet, ist jetzt unser Innenminister und will an die Daten ran. Also ich muss mich jetzt mal aufregen, aber das gefällt mir wirklich nicht, was da draußen passiert.
Er macht in seiner Art weiter. Das Besteuerte ist ja, dass wir sie weitermachen lassen.
Das ist es eben immer. Wir wählen sie, ja.
Da hab ich eine Alternative außer den Schrottchen.
Es gibt immer Alternativen.
Kommt zum Chaos Communication Kongress. Da gibt es dann praktische Hinweise.
Wenn er vielleicht inhaltlich die mehrwertige Logik von Gotthard Günther mit aufnehmen würde, um das mal als neue Mathematik oder als neue Werkzeug für Systemanalysen einzuführen, wenn staatliche Institutionen, die ihn nicht schon haben und einsetzen, soft und hardwaremäßig, wäre das vielleicht mal interessant.
Gotthard Günther?
Ja, Gotthard Günther war ein alter Mathematiker und Philosoph. Er hat unter anderem die mehrwertige Logik in die Welt gesetzt, ob er verstanden wird von der damaligen Zeit, als er gelebt hat, er ist schon ein paar Jahre tot, wahrscheinlich nicht. Und das ist eher in einem kleinen eingeweihten Kreis ein Geheimtipp.
Das mit der Logik ist doch eigentlich gelöst. Also ich meine, da hat sich doch irgendwie mal, also spätestens seit Turing und seit Gödel wissen wir halt, dass das mit der Logik eh arbitrier ist und irgendwie keine logikvollständige Aussagen bringen wird.
Was heißt arbitrier?
Na, dass du quasi die Logiken beliebig zusammenbauen kannst aus beliebigen Aktionen und ganz egal, was dein Aktionensystem ist. Du hast immer Aussagen, die du nicht entscheiden kannst im Aktionensystem oder du hast Aussagen, die wirsprüchlich sind im Aktionensystem. Und demzufolge kann man beliebig viele Logiken erfinden und kann damit irgendwie sich Sachen anders angucken.
Auch ein Thema mal für eine Sendung, oder?
Das ist spannend, das ging ja bei den Philosophen los. Hat nur ein bisschen in der 23, aber kann man glaube ich nochmal...
Das sollten wir dringend nochmal machen. Gut, hab ich wieder was zu lesen. Vielen Dank Reinhard. Das letzte Wort am Telefon hat der Jens. Hallo Jens.
Hallo, ist ja ein Ding, das letzte Wort...
Am Telefon.
Am Telefon, genau. Und zwar erstmal auch wie gesagt nochmal Dankeschön für die vielen Jahre Chaos Computer Club. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab recht früh mal reingehört. Da ging es darum, wie der Name entstanden ist, weil ich stamm auch aus dieser Ostseite hier und kenne noch das Chaos-Menü vom KC damals.
So wie DOS, weißt du?
Ja, ich weiß gerade Chaos.
Da hab ich so ein bisschen laufen gelernt mit Basic und so eine Geschichten und dann ewig überhaupt nichts gemacht und zwischendurch immer noch so ein bisschen antiquierte Technik zu Hause und arbeite noch mit relativ viereinzigerem System, 98er. Da entwickelt ja keiner mehr so richtig was, weil das ja am Aussterben ist.
Macht ja keine Hoffnung.
Meinst du nicht?
Also keine großen.
Naja, ich sag mal so, es ist ja so, dass man da auch mehr vor sitzt und wartet, dass da was passiert, als dass man mitarbeiten kann. Ist ja auch eine andere Geschichte.
Also quasi das, äh...
Du sitzt vor der Maschine und wartest auf den Virenbefall, ja?
Nö, so nicht. Ja, bin ich relativ sorglos in der Frage.
Okay, ansonsten hätte ich empfohlen, mal in den Wald zu gehen, den Moos beim Wachsen zu zuschauen.
Ja, nee, was ich sagen wollte, ich hab noch irgendwo hier ab und zu schneide ich die Sendung mit und jetzt in einer relativ alten Konserve mal gehört zu so einer Sendung, wo eure Server abgesoffen waren im Keller.
Ja, legendär. Ich hätte gerne das Video noch. Es gibt ein Video dazu. Erinnert ihr euch nicht mehr, nachdem wir hier in dieses neue Gebäude umgezogen sind?
Ich erinnere mich an das Video, ich hab das Video gesehen.
Irgendwer hat ein Video gemacht und hat es hier bei uns ins Intranet gestellt. Und das ist ein Video, unter diesem Studio, Tim. Wann sind wir hier? Als das Studio neu bezogen wurde. Es gab Starkregen und irgendwie hat der Architekt sich gedacht, naja, das Fenster da unten unterhalb der Grasnarbe, das muss ich hier nicht abdichten. Oder was auch immer der sich dabei gedacht hat. Herrlich, das Video hätte ich gerne auch nochmal.
Jedenfalls hatte ich den Anfang von der Sendung mitgeschnitten. Ich weiß nicht mehr, welche Sendung das war. Wenn ihr da Interesse habt und vielleicht die dann nicht vollständig habt, könnte ich ja auch nochmal gucken, ob wir dazugucken.
Guck einfach, wenn ihr irgendwas habt, her damit, ich nehme alles.
Und da, welche Adresse? Einfach auf der Homepage.
Chaosradio, lcccde kommt immer an.
Schokolade fressen und dann im Radio was sagen?
Ja, wir haben jetzt immer ein bisschen die Pralinen ausgepackt.
Schokolade, so.
Schick, einfach. Also, ihr werdet schon wegengefinden, euch erfolgreich mit uns in Kontakt zu setzen.
Ist ja kaum vermeidbar. Vielen Dank.
Ebenso Grüße nach Jachimstal. Damit sind wir schon wieder fast am Ende.
Ja, dabei gibt es noch so viel zu erzählen.
Wie immer.
Ja, immer das gleiche. Echt.
Auftrag erfüllt über die Jahre? Ich frag noch mal.
Was war denn gleich der Auftrag?
Tja, du hast mir gestern in deinem Mikrofon gesagt, wir im Auftrag des Herrn unterwegs. Nein, im Namen des Herrn sogar.
Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Das ist ja ein fortgesetzter Auftrag. Wir versuchen auch zu vermitteln, eine Selbstverständnisse des TCCs ist, dass man sich halt so auch als in der Mittlerrolle sieht zwischen einer Öffentlichkeit, sowohl einer privaten Öffentlichkeit, als auch einer Regierungsöffentlichkeit, gesetzgebenden Öffentlichkeit und auch einer Businessöffentlichkeit. Als Mittler zu einer Szene, die einfach dadurch besticht, dass sie die Technologien, die im Einsatz sind und vor allem auch die demnächst in den Einsatz kommen könnten oder definitiv werden, einfach besser verstehen, aber eben Schwierigkeiten haben, das zu übersetzen. Und das ist sicherlich einer der Aufgaben, die wir versucht haben, hier gerecht zu werden.
Mal mehr, mal weniger.
Und wenn es nach uns ging, dann würden wir das auch die nächsten 10 Jahre noch tun.
Genau.
Genau. Und das nächste Mal tun wir das. Ich guck jetzt mal in den Kalender hier, damit das Ganze noch einen halbprofessionellen Anstrich kriegt, das nächste Chaosradio. Chaosradio 109 gibt es dann am letzten Mittwoch im Januar. Das ist der 25. Januar. Bis dahin hört ihr euch den Chaosradio Express an und was da sonst über den Podcast kommt, chaosradio.ccc.de. Da kommt der Empfang, heißt das glaube ich.
Ja genau, schickt uns einfach auch fleißig E-Mails zu dem Thema, wie ihr euch das vorstellt und so weiter. Wir sind da aufnahmefähig.
Und falls euch zwischenzeitlich dann noch mehr CCC abgeht, dann geht ihr doch ganz einfach vielleicht zum Kongress.
Genau.
Nach dem 21.
Chaos Communication Kongress, 27.
bis 30.
Dezember 2005. Es wird ein ganz großartiger Kongress. Wir haben ein Programm, das ist pickepacke voll, obwohl es jetzt schon vier Tage ist. Und es sprechen Bundestagsabgeordnete bei uns, es sprechen Leute über den neuesten Forschung im Bereich der Sicherheitstechnik, aber auch ganz andere abgefahrene Geschichten.
Es ist für jeden wirklich was dabei.
Genau, wir werden im Podcast auch einige der Vorträge vorstellen in den nächsten Wochen zum Kongress. So viele sind es ja gar nicht mehr. Und wir reden uns den Mundfusselig. Das ist am Alexanderplatz im Übrigen, haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt, an Berliner Kongress in der Dorfhütte, das ganze Stadt. So, Schluss mit Informationen.
Chaosradio 108 ist zu Ende. 10 Jahre Chaosradio war das. Wir hoffen, dass wir weitere 10 Jahre bei euch sein können, auf welche Art und Weise auch immer. Vielen Dank, Andreas. Vielen Dank, Jens. Vielen Dank, Tim. Danke schön. Gerne meine ich, bitteschön. Bitte danke.
Nochmal ein Filmzitat bitte.
Bist du immer so sicher.
Vielleicht noch zum Abschluss. Eigentlich war jemand anders hier geplant, Peter Glaser, konnte kurzfristig da nicht. Dafür ist Andreas dankenswetterweise eingesprungen. Und wenn wir jetzt irgendwie in die Zukunft decken, von Peter Glaser gibt es einen schönen Spruch, es gibt keine Zukunft, alles ist Gegenwart.
Wollen wir noch ein bisschen Glaser lesen, bis die Stunde rum ist?
Glaser Lesung, bis die Stunde rum ist. Nein, wir sagen noch mal, wo die Musik herkam, weil ich hab ein paar Mails gekriegt an meine Fritz Adresse, die fragen, was das für eine Musik ist. Die Musik, die wir gehört haben und die ihr gehört habt, die findet ihr allesamt unter starfrosch.ch.
Genau, in diesem Fall sind es so die DJ-Mixer, die da zuletzt aus dem Feed rausgekullert sind, das werdet ihr leicht finden können. Da gibt es eine eigene Kategorie dafür. Starfrosch.ch ist ein sehr ergiebiger Podcast für elektronische Musikkala.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, die schmeißen so viel raus, dass man mit dem Hören eigentlich gar nicht nachkommt. Es geht weiter, und zwar mit dem Nightschleit und Martin Petersdorf. Das war Chaosradio 108. Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit. Gute Nacht.
Computer-free, computer-free, leht's in deiner Welt. Hacks mit dicken Fingern in die Tastatur. Computer-free, computer-free, abgeschottet, ausgesperrt, suchst im Chat Erlösung und findest nur dich selbst. Wirklichkeit und Fantasie verschmelzen zu ein Klumpen aus virtueller Masse und binären Codes. Fast klar vom Arbeitsspeicher hockst du in deiner Butze. Essen tust du nur doch, um zu überleben. Computer-free, computer-free, ungeraschen, klebrig, Emotions-Schock gefrostet, verheddert in der Maus. Computer-free, computer-free, von Mega-Herz zu Mega-Schmerz ist das nun das Leben, was du wirklich willst. Abhängig von Updates, Augen gerendert, ungelenkt dein Körper, Sklave deiner Zeit. Festplatte raucht ab, Backup geht verloren, Angst um nächsten Absturz, wer beherrscht hier wen? Computer-free, computer-free, Klicks depressiv im Off, Arbeitsspeicher chronisch knapp, Taktung ist beschissen, Computer-free, computer-free, beidseitig formatierbar, Gefangener von Beidts, Joystick der Gefühle, das Hirn verklumpt mit Datenbrei, Controlling ausgeschlossen, ist das die schöne Neue Welt oder Horror-Trip? Verdammter Einmannstraße aus Elektrosmog, dazwischen niemals landen auf Omas und Beamten. Computer-free, computer-free, digitales Koma, analoge Zucken in virtueller Qual. Computer-free, computer-free, Gefangener des Laufwerks, der Diener wird zum Herrscher, der Sklave wird zum Gott. Computer-free, computer-free, Ami der Laptop-Zombies, schlecht getaktet, falsch gepolt, auf DVD versklavt. Computer-free, computer-free, jung und krank im oft gedunsen, eklig fetter Fleischklop, festgebackt am Schirm.